[Musique]
avec nous ce soir
thibault chanel rose jean jacques debout
chantal goya
bernard henri lévy
haya landa
justin
c'est nier que la moitié
non
mes bons amis
la pluie
fortement
et maintenant
[Musique]
j'accueille philippe de gaulle
oui
[Musique]
bonsoir amiral on soir monsieur
l'addition alors ce quel effet ça vous
fait d'être à la télévision est ce que
vous avez le trac quand vous venez à la
télévision oh moi j'ai pas de talent ni
de goût particulier pour la télévision
prêts provenant de la marine nationale
nous pratiquions la discrétion
ouais mais mon père c'est différent il
avait appris votre père a pris d avant
guerre il avait d'abord compris
l'importance de médias il l'a appliqué
pendant la guerre bien sûr l'appel du 18
juin pour commencer et puis c'est un
métier qui l'a appris finalement au fur
et à mesure des années jusqu à le
pratiquer avec une certaine maîtrise
quand il est devenu président de la
république moi je me souviens en mai 68
quand il a fait son allocution à la
radio on était avec des amis étudiants
révolutionnaires dans un parc public et
on l'a entendu à la radio il a retourné
tout le monde en vain discours a été
très très fort en radio oui d'autant que
la télévision ne marchait pas ouais
voilà il n'avait que la radio et la
radio sur transistors alors pour ceux
qui voudraient pas reconnu philippe de
gaulle et le fils de charles de gaulle
ancien inspecteur général de la marine
depuis 1986 sénateur ump de paris
alors évidemment c'est pas facile d'être
le fils du général de gaulle mais vous
avez accepté votre destin avec courage
et modestie vous dit j'aurais pu naître
fils de pygmées ou de banc tout le sort
en a décidé autrement
on ne choisit pas sa place pour vous
votre place implique plus de plus de
devoirs que de droits d'une certaine
façon
non je dirais autant de devoirs que de
droits il faut pas diminuer ce qui c'est
très urgent de devoir goliat droit oui
tout à fait tout à fait
ben oui mais c'est ainsi il faut assumer
la place que le sort vous attribuez
ouais alors bien que fils du général de
gaulle vous n'avez jamais cédé à la
facilité à 20 ans vous choisissez
l'armée la marine
ensuite pendant la guerre vous sillonnez
la manche dans les vedettes lance
torpilles des forces françaises libres
donc une guerre très très courageuse
vous débarquez avec la 2e db et vous
participez à la meurtrière campagne
d'alsace donc tout le monde connaît
l'action de votre père pendant la guerre
mais on peut dire que vous aussi
philippe de gaulle vu une action très
très courageuse a oui je ne pouvais pas
être autrement qu'être en première ligne
y compris dans la deuxième division
blindée alors il ya eu deux mille livres
écrits sur le général de gaulle votre
père mais jamais le témoignage de
quelqu'un d'aussi proche son propre fils
vous êtes le dernier témoin privilégié
vivant vous dites après mois on fera du
roman vous êtes le dernier à pouvoir
certifier de ce qui s'écrit puisque ma
soeur aussi discrète que ma mère
garde le silence il n'y a donc plus
qu'un seul témoin et le moment est venu
pour moi de témoigner
après on écrira ce qu'on voudra mais en
moins en [__] le plus d'éléments que
possible et en tout cas plus que ce
qu'on en a maintenant à en juger par ce
qu'on écrit parfois enfin
d'affabulations ou deux interprétations
abusives
combien de fois ai-je entendu dire que
mon père disait l'intendant suivre oui
c'est vrai il n'a jamais dit ça au
contraire pour lui la tendance précédait
toujours
alors donc à 81 ans vous parlez philippe
de gaulle dans un livre événement un
livre d'entretiens avec l'écrivain
journaliste michel tauriac qui s'appelle
de gaulle mon père qui est édité chez
plon
alors ce livre évidemment fourmille
d'informations historiques et d'éléments
plus personnel à commencer par la
difficulté à s'appeler de gaulle vous
dit finalement que pouvait pas passer
une journée aujourd'hui sans entendre
parler du général de gaulle c'est vrai
on a ses propres parents disparus en soi
même on vit avec eux mais en plus je ne
peux pas passer un jour sans voir mon
nom écrit le nom de mon père pour une
question ou une autre alors en plus
comme vous lui ressemblez énormément
vous le savez vous pouvez pas aller dans
le métro peut pas le cinéma c'est c'est
très difficile pour vous ça fait partie
de nos statuts ouais c'est ce qu'on doit
assumer c'est comme ça alors quand
avez-vous pris conscience du fait que
votre père n'était pas comme les autres
qu'il était différent voire supérieurs
aux tréteaux way très tôt je dirais 4 5
en 1
alors je sais que tous les petits
garçons se lisent mon père est
formidable elle est toujours le mieux
etc
mais tout de même je me suis aperçu que
le personnage central c'était toujours
lui même quand il ne disait rien et
d'ailleurs dans le
l'ouvragé que je publie envoie une photo
du sous lieutenant charles de gaulle au
33ème régiment d'infanterie qui au bout
de table des jeunes à la popote en
campagne avec les officiers de son
bataillon qui a des vieux capitaine ya
le commandant en chef de bataillon il ya
beaucoup de mais on ne voit qu'un seul
personnage s'est lui arrêté en bout de
table
et pourtant s'il n'y a que lui qu'on
voit l'enfance assez difficile quand
même discipline assez ferme à la maison
est ce que votre père vous mettez des
baffes enfin des gifles non si vous
voulez me faire dire que nous avions une
éducation trop y tiennent certainement
pas près des bas-fonds n'en reçoivent
est quand on était petit d'ailleurs
c'est comme ça que la lionne réagi avec
le lion esso et où l'ours avec le petit
il faut le ramener dans le droit chemin
et que faire avec un petit qui met la
main dans la soupe
la ville de nantes après voilà son ca et
bien c'était les coutumes du milieu
auquel j'appartenais il fallait être
dans un moule et répondre quand on vous
adresser la parole
voilà à table les enfants par les pattes
encore à table les ans qu'on pouvait
parler pas si j'entendais interrogé par
il devient vais rien réclamer d'autres
chansons là si on les avait oubliés ou
s'ils n'avaient pas de cuillères ou deux
il ne disait rien ne vais rien dire
votre mère avait quand même la main un
petit peu plus lourde que votre père ma
mère avait besoin de s'affirmer un peu
plus ouais mon père avait une autorité
naturelle sur elles reculé pas besoin de
s'imposer
votre mère était pas très maternelle à
ma mère était une mère parfaite
c'est à dire que ses enfants avaient
tout ce qu'elle pouvait leur donner
mais une les mignardises est pas née
carrés ces prêts ne les sauve cotisent
était très petit vos parents philippe de
gaulle former un couple la discrétion
s'impose est celle que quand votre père
rentré à la maison
il embrassait votre mère sur les joues
sur le ferons jamais sur la bouche
devant vous ah non jamais jamais jamais
vu non il embrasse fait c'était
considéré comme le comportement du
couple en public à votre père suivait de
près vos études
ils apprenaient des fables et des poèmes
par coeur pour vous les faire réciter
tout ça a un sens et il la prenait
lui-même ce qui lui fit lisait trois
fois le poème mois la mrc oui en ce
faisant se raser pour m'indiquer comment
on devait le réciter alors vous dites je
devais être parmi les dix premiers de la
classe il fallait que je sois avant les
autres c'était obligatoire oui il disait
ça m'est égal que
tu es un demi point si les autres en 0
alors finalement vous rentrez dans la
marine il sait jamais vraiment mêlée de
votre carrière
il n'a jamais jamais beaucoup intervenu
dans votre carré militaire
finalement il a failli vous oublié dans
ses mémoires de guerre et là il a oublié
finalement vous étiez comportés en héros
pendant la guerre et rhône ont quand
même
et là il a rajouté il a rajouté de sa
main sur le sont les manuscrits monfils
continue à se battre avec la 2e db
comment vous expliquez ça comment vous
expliquer que finalement il vous est
tellement mis de côté à ce moment là et
bien parce que il était en train
d'écrire ses mémoires de guerre mais il
ne raconte pas l'histoire de sa propre
famille a pas une
ce matin c'est la discrétion et puis je
lui ai dit à la fin tout de même vous
pourriez dire que votre propre fils a
fait le tour de bout en bout et pas à
l'arrière il a dit oui c'est vrai mais
je sais pas pour raconter l'histoire de
ma famille alors il a rajouté monfils
continue à se battre
il s'agissait de la libération de paris
point final il aurait pu peut-être ça
aurait pu arriver
écrire mon fils a été tué il n'a pas été
le seul
ouais ouais vous en avez vous lu de voir
aussi peu de considération finalement
pour vos beaux faits d'armes pendant la
guerre
pas du tout ils le savaient ils savaient
très bien ça ne sert à rien d'être le
fils du général de gaulle quand il faut
affronter deux nuits sur un porte-avions
et il faut accosté à bas taux aux côtes
il faut être fair lentilles chars avec
la première ligne d'avants tri ça sert
absolument à rien alors c'est pas la
peine qu'ils s'emmêlent a alors sur le
plan historique fille de gaulle vous
apporter un éclairage évidemment sur le
mois de juin 40
le refus de paul reynaud le président du
conseil de quitter la france
il ya sa décision à lui de partir en
angleterre de se jeter à l'eau dit il et
de s'en remettre à dieu sert qu'à un
moment et c'est un jet ski et fondateur
pour tous pour tous qui suit après c'est
qu'à un moment il est entré dans la
rébellion il a franchi le rubicon il
savait pas où il allait il a été tout
seul contre tous oui mais il se
considérait pas comme rebelle il était
secrétaire d'état d'un gouvernement et
il considérait que de la troisième
république et il considérait que le
reste étant sol influence de l'ennemi ne
comptait pas voilà qu'elle était
toujours sous les lois de la troisième
république
il n'y avait pour lui aucun changement
de régime et il ne se considérait pas
comme rebelle il considérait que c'est
les autres avaient failli mais lui
continuer s'il devait continuer comme il
le disait parce que c'est l'honneur
les tous nos alliés continuent le combat
aux côtés des anglais y compris ceux qui
sont envahis comme les polonais les
hollandais et tout il n'y a que nous qui
ne compterait pas c'est l'intérêt
supérieur de la france parce que il faut
qu'elle soit victorieuse à la fin avec
tous les autres est ce le bon sens parce
que les allemands perdons souvent se dit
dans la vie d'aujourd'hui
soixante ans après on se dit qu'est ce
que j'aurais fait moi le 18 juin 40 est
ce que je serais parti à londres où
est-ce que j'aurais accepté finalement
l'occupation ou le pétainisme
c'est une question qui est central
toujours aujourd'hui dans la dans la vie
des français c'est une question qu'on se
pose très souvent
oui mais il y avait beaucoup de jeunes
gens l'époque qui n'acceptait pas qu'il
effondrement de la france que pour eux
ça paraissait incroyable
c'était d'ailleurs effectivement
incroyable et aurait voulu se battre ou
continuer n'ont pas pu parce qu'ils se
sont trouvés très vite bloqué alors vous
et votre famille philippe de gaulle
embarquez donc à brest sur un rafiot
propos l'angleterre et quand vous
arrivez à fall malte vous savez pas
vraiment où est votre père le général de
gaulle et c'est là vous voyez dans le
journal un entrefilet 10 ans qui a lancé
un appel la veille dont on connaît le 19
juin
oui il a été soumis à un rythme
absolument épuisant les dix derniers
jours du gouvernement français il
faisait l'aller retour de grande
bretagne france dans les 24 heures il
aller à tour y revenait il aller à
bordeaux il retournait à brest et par
conséquent il était fréquemment
grande-bretagne disons tous les 48
heures donc on savait que mon père
pouvait être en grande bretagne mais
nous n'étions pas sûrs de les retrouver
et nous avons traversé pour une autre
raison c'est comme j'avais une soeur
très infirme qui ne marchait pas et
qu'on ne pouvez pas déplacer en voiture
d'ailleurs n'avions pas de voitures
n'ayant veut pas en train pas en quarts
alors ne pas nous laisser dépasser par
les allemands c'est la consigne que nous
avions partir du bretagne nord où nous
étions en vacances pour aller à nantes
ou à bordeaux avec cette fille infirme
mr a décidé que ce serait plus simple
par prendre un bateau pour aller en
grande bretagne ce qu'elle avait fait en
1914 déjà une fois alors ensuite
philippe de gaulle vous commenter un
certain nombre d'événements historiques
de la deuxième guerre mondiale le
sabordage de la flotte à mers-el-kébir
laprise raté de dakar l'assassinât de
darlan la dénonciation de jean moulin et
surtout l'affirmation du général de
gaulle à l'issue de la guerre pour
imposer la france comme un des
vainqueurs pour redonner dit-il le moral
à la nation après que le ressort était
cassé puisque l'effondrement politique
était devenue totale
mon père a considéré qu'il n'était pas
un commandant d'art de forces armées et
qu'il défendrait les intérêts du peuple
français
il a toujours fait valoir autant à
l'ennemi qu'à ses propres alliés que le
peuple français est incontournable et
qu'il fallait toujours compter avec lui
c'est ainsi qu'il a commencé à prendre
un rôle politique souvent d'ailleurs
inconfortable pour tes alliés vive de
gaulle cette idée de dire aux français
finalement la france s'est bien
comportée de leur faire croire un petit
peu qu'ils ont tous été résistant
pendant la guerre ça partait d'un bon
sentiment
pour redresser le moral de la nation non
c'est historiquement c'est faux tout de
même
nous ne sommes effondrés en 1940 parce
que nous à vous et y ont mal organisé
nous avions des préjugés militaire
périmés et nous étions mal commandé
ouais car nous étions dans une
république était déjà très usés ouais
donc les armées étaient mal commandé
mais tout de même il faut pas oublier
que en mai juin 40
les français ont eu c'est 116000 tuées
et 600 mille blessés
oui mais quand nous étions tous seuls
oui mais d'un camp mais après après la
guerre quand votre père faisait les
comptes vous voyez le nombre de gens qui
avaient été dans la résistance sur sûr
c'est pas moi sur 40 ou 45 millions
d'habitants à l'époque ça faisait pas
beaucoup quand même
il y avait 40 millions 39 y avait
beaucoup d'attentes east c'est vrai mais
il y avait quand même une proportion de
résistants qui petit à petit ma pu être
répertorié monte environ 40000
résistants patenté enregistrés dans des
réseaux une centaine de milliers
d'autres qui n'étaient pas dans des
réseaux mais qui les ont aidés et qui
ont risqué la capture ou même d'être
fusillé environ deux ou trois cent mille
autres qui les ont aidés ouais les le
peuple français c'est quand même résisté
à résister tout de même quand tu es
gamin il aura donné beaucoup
d'importance à se convertir alors bien
sûr pour des raisons politiques mais
aussi morale alors vous parlez aussi
donc de l'épuration son refus de gracier
des écrivains collaborationniste qui lui
a été beaucoup reproché notamment
brasillach laval fusillé alors qu'il
était dans le coma
parce qu'il ait fait une tentative de
suicide il a voulu se suicider en
absorbant un poison qui était
partiellement périmés mais il serait
mort de toute façon on aurait pu le
laisser mourir mais ce qu'a dit votre
père soit là
il avait alors le maréchal pétain à
votre père voulait qu'il soit qu'il soit
condamné
évidemment en sachant qu'il allait le
grâcier qu'il ne laisserait pas fusillé
mais ils disent
si moi j'étais tombé dans les mains de
vichy il aurait pas eu autant de
clémence avec moi a incontestablement il
aurait tout de suite été fusil et
d'ailleurs et les allemands ne leur est
exigé
ouais oui ce qui fait qu'ils ont fait
deux procès successifs 1 ils l'ont
d'abord réduit au grade de colonel et
allah et à une amende
et puis sans doute les allemands ont-ils
protester et un mois pourraient ils ont
réuni un conseil de guerre qui à ce
moment-là l'a condamné à mort est la
confiscation de ses biens ray et à la
perte de sa nationalité
donc il aux réfugiés alors que lui n'a
pas fait fusiller pétarade août à l'île
d'yeu
ouais souvent quand on part en france
des américains et de l'anti américanisme
on se réfère au général de gaulle et
j'ai retrouvé une phrase dans votre
livre qui est finalement assez
d'actualité aujourd'hui
est-ce que
c'est ne pas aimer les américains de
considérer qu'ils n'ont pas à décider
pour la france non chaque pays défendre
son peuple ses intérêts qui sont pas les
mêmes il faut rappeler ce que le papier
que les états unis remettait à chaque
soldat américain qui débarquait en
france et qui était intitulé vous n'êtes
pas là pour libérer la france mais pour
combattre un ennemi des états unis ouais
ouais
même si vous libérer la france c'est pas
le but de fait tous les français même
ceux qui ont libéré les états unis en
1786 au temps des guerres d'amérique
sont morts en réalité pour la france
pour le roi qui le représentait à
l'époque comme les américains les
soldats américains qui ont été tués sont
morts pour les états unis d'amérique et
les français pour la france c'est tout
chacun a ses intérêts et sa personnalité
propre à défendre aussi il faut voir que
les journalistes souvent parce que ça
faisait de la copie exagérait les
différends qui pouvait y avoir même s'il
y avait des différences fondamentales il
y en avait c'est bien bien sûr les états
unis étaient à leur place et nous à la
nôtre est-ce que l'attitude de la france
face à la guerre d'irak vous semble dans
la ligne gaullienne de votre père très
certainement oui certainement
mon père se serait d'abord demandé qu
avons nous affaire dans ce pays en étant
donné que nous ne pouvons rien réglé
nous français il s'agit de nous français
il s'agit pas les autres donc le
gaullisme perdure d'une certaine façon
le golif perdure ouais alors y'en a qui
voudraient qu'ils ne perdure pas dur il
perdure en tous les cas oui alors à
l'époque où votre père est parti pour
londres évidemment l'opinion publique
était favorable à pétain il a décidé lui
d'incarner tout seul la résistance face
aux nazis
à votre avis aujourd'hui contre quoi
devons-nous résister contre la décadence
la contre la perte de confiance en nous
mêmes
mon père écrivait la france vient du
fond des âges
elle vit les siècles l'appel et quelle
que soit la situation
elles restent elles mêmes donc la france
qui tombe pour vous ça se corrige et
celles qui se laisse aller ouais
d'accord alors à l'époque de radio
londres on disait les français parlent
aux français
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que les français
devraient dire aux français a il faut
pas se laisser aller au déclin mais faut
toujours garder
l'avenir n'est jamais inéluctable
ouais les choses les choses ne sont pas
on ne peut pas savoir trois ans quatre
ans cinq ans après ce qui va se passer
les choses ne sont pas réglées davance
une fois pour toutes ces absences et
l'histoire et il n'y a pas de sens de
l'histoire ce n'est pas vrai c'est une
fausse théorie qui était une doctrine
mais une doctrine très ancienne
alors vous n'êtes pas désespérer
sérieusement aujourd'hui de voir qu'en
france il y a pas d'homme politique de
l'envergure de la stature de votre père
tout le monde peut pas être le général
de gaulle c'est ce que disait georges
pompidou quand il lui a succédé un jour
m'invitant à dîner la seule fois où il
met invitait d'ailleurs après mon père
plusieurs années il m'a dit qu'est ce
que vous voulez je fais comme je peux je
ne suis pas le général de gaulle d'un
oui il n'est pas le général de gaulle
les chinois m'ont dit un personnage
comme votre père il y en a un tous les
siècles où tous les deux siècles dans
chaque pays
alors on a beaucoup de parler de votre
père philippe de gaulle
j'aimerais avant nous séparait qu'on
dise un mot sur votre fils qui s'appelle
charles de gaulle qui est au front
national
de gaulle et le pen sur la même affiche
ça vous fait quoi on monfils l'âge du
premier ministre
mon grand père est mort il ya trente
trois ans et on n'accuse pas d'autre
chose d'autre
la faire et c'est à lui de voir son
affaire ça vous a désolé ça ne
m'entraînais pas sur ce sujet je vous
répondrai pas il est majeur et vacciné
merci merci d'avoir été prévu a ajouté
quelque chose pour les plus jeunes qui
nous entende on représente trop souvent
le général de gaulle comme un dinosaure
way or personne ne sait plus adaptée à
son temps au temps qu'il avait il a
connu trois cultures trois civilisations
que le général de gaulle et il faut que
tous ceux qui sont ici autour se
souviennent que l'inventeur et lé
incitateur l'organisateur de la sécurité
sociale et des assedic c'est lui vote
des femmes
le voit des femmes est aussi le régime
bilité de la même façon que les hommes
du texte et que quand il monte dans un
tgv c'est le choix du général de gaulle
il a choisi le tgv contre le turbo train
ou le train un coussin d'air le concorde
celle général de gaulle la airs l'airbus
qui s'appelait aéro bus super caravelle
et caravelles celle général de gaulle
le nucléaire c'est le général de gaulle
le périphérique autour de paris et les
autoroutes c'est le général de gaulle
alors voilà pour le passé en réalité le
général de gaulle était un dernier merci
beaucoup merci si diego
entretien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
question et je suis juste positive
années 90 les attendent et je vais
présenter ça va c'est un miracle je vous
présente jamais de vous présenter sa
valeur quand dieu je connecte nouveaux
aéroports tous les reproches et
satisfaire par orange qui attend juste
géante écoute moi qu'est ce qu'il fait
là
ouais comme je sais que tu as beaucoup
de boulot hein tu travaille comme un
forcené c'est vrai j'ai préparé le but
c'est très intéressant long à lire prend
son temps wipro de surtemps évidemment
c'est parce que j'aurai comme j'ai pas
le temps moi c'est pour ça j'ai gelé
styrie lire il me racontait hier les
regarde tout le monde en parle pour
savoir ce que dans l'ailé fléchissement
est très bien organisée alors en tout
cas observé que pour le radio lounge
équipe aussi je vous ai déjà dit et
l'appel du 18 juin comme je suis né le
18 juin ça me fait kiffer ses partisans
à travers charles de gaulle est
cependant personne rien à dire à
quelqu'un alors j'étais en train d'être
tentée ce conte moi moi je décris les
questions pour pas que tu perds ton
temps tu m'as fait des questions avant
tout pour éviter de me poser des
questions à la cour du style tromper csu
c'est l'accord qui les lie pépère je me
ménage fait comme si j'étais pas au
courant de questions bon vous restait
cinq minutes avec nous je vous remercie
japon
djamel qu'est ce que vous faites là
n'entend jamais avant chanel dont gmail
qui se bat tu respires jamais benjamin a
oui je crois que c'était benjam elle
bonsoir mon sauf thierry après ces
immenses triomphe que vous avez
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui dans les acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
djamel si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est
ce que ça vous fait aujourd'hui à moins
de 30 ans de vous retrouver au panthéon
des acteurs français
[Applaudissements]
question ouais le panthéon c'est la fin
on lui là encore 30 ans il a beaucoup de
choses à faire l'achat alors jamais
c'est vraiment un honneur et un immense
privilège d'avoir l'honneur de vous
avoir ce soir parmi nous après ces
immenses triomphe que vous avez
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui dans les acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est ce que
ça fait aujourd'hui de vous retrouver au
panthéon des acteurs français
je sais pas si on peut dire ça comme ça
ouais je j'ai bâti ce qui est portée aux
arcs de triomphe tour eiffel j'en ai
rien à [__]
c'est plus difficile c'est pas moi c'est
les jo c'est les autres qui vont au
moins une certaine navailles
extraordinaire moi je subis plus tu vois
je suis pas trop grand je fais je fais
les choses naturellement pensé c'est le
style c'est le style c'est clair
pourtant djamel d'après le journal de
mickey vous êtes l'acteur préféré les
enfants je tiens à remercier les enfants
en particulier pour pour ça c'est vrai
et c'est s'est joué ça s'est joué à ça
entre moi et plus tôt et c'est vrai
qu'entre un chien débile il a rappelé
qu'à la classe et autres et ferait le
reste
[Applaudissements]
comme elle jamel c'est quoi vos plus
grandes qualités à part bien sûr la
bogossité la générosité la même minute
et ça et iris est très difficile de
parler de soi
ouais j'ai envie de dire là la modestie
oui oui oui modestie c'est bien aussi si
ça vous fait de gens modestes ou très
modestes aussi philippe devaux la pluie
est une vedette
achi alors est ce qu'il vend des livres
c'est incroyable il faut vingt mille
livres par jour j'ai vu que c'est une
énorme mais avant de 500000 la rêverie
comme quoi c'est normal et les premières
notes son effigie et d'équité comme des
aéroports des deux métros voici voici
ses amis voilà c'est ça que voir faire
aussi un jour y arrivent à l'aéroport
qui s'appelle le jamel debbouze comment
je kifferais steven jyles
[Applaudissements]
magie t'imagines si philippe devaux le
premier du pognon sur charles de gaulle
roissy charles de gaulle étoile station
charles de gaulle est il fou ils
pourraient s'acheter pas de cravate
bordeaux
jamel est ce que tant qu'il est là
est ce que est ce que tu as une question
à lui poser philippe de gaulle vous êtes
donc le fils forcément de charles est ce
que il aimer le rap est ce qu'ils
connaissaient tupac shakur ou biggie
smalls par exemple de son temps ça ne
s'appelait pas comme ça il lui arrivait
de danse et de partir en vrille ou par
an chez nous on est regardé les gens
danser mais jamais jamais voulait
prendre pris en flag dans votre salon en
train de la mer jamais non jamais jalel
change est épuisé il était très strict
carpostal non c'est pas ça mais comme ce
n'était pas dans son talent il préférait
regarder ceux dont le talent mais parce
qu'on voit les chefs d'état en aide
de mon point de vue en tout cas je suis
pas chef d'état de mon état je me dis
que y
ils sont toujours obligés tout le temps
toute leur vie d'être sérieux oui sans
doute sérieux mais ça les empêche pas de
s'amuser parfois mais ça reste quand
même s'ils sont pas sourire et qu'on les
voit pas rire il ya des choses qui les
amuse il n'a jamais une touche
d'expérience du frère de temps il et il
était plutôt gentil plus tôt et tous
âges plutôt chefs d'état les gentilles
et et chatila ils avaient affaire avec
difficulté et forcément il n'y a pas que
ça ferme c'est réparé
on l'avait fait venir pour ça on a ça
c'était un peu aller le chercher pour
aller le chercher dans tout un
ça fait comme on dit chez moi merci
beaucoup merci ville yves le borgne
et maintenant l'effort du pénitencier
[Musique]
bientôt 20 ans
fermée
voici jean jacques debout
[Musique]
jacques de nouer
ça va bonjour série a vu je me suis fait
faire une coupe banias comme ça t'es pas
dépaysés ça va parce que vous savez que
jean jacques debout et là messieurs à
passer l'été au frais 1
c'est le cas de le dire comment ça va la
santé ça va mieux mais au début de la
canicule je le redis avait commencé la
fleuriste voilà comment ça va la santé
est là ça va ça oui ça va je m'ennuie de
mes camarades
bah ouais c'est normal dans vos
camarades de mitard justement jean
jacques
ils étaient impressionnés que vous ayez
composé boubane petit ourson sûrement
nord avait dit en arrivant que c'est moi
qui fais booba le petit ourson donc d'un
seul coup respect celui qui vole un nom
mais il a chanté un coup oui c'est vrai
jusqu'à 5 heures du matin avant donc
début juillet jean-jacques vous rentrez
chez vous bourrez accident sans gravité
un celui-là le premier la boulevard rené
coty pas de problème puisque sinon sympa
quoi chaque accrochage l'accident de
quartier ouais le petit accrochage tout
seul accrochage quand même oui pas de
permis pendant six mois mais enfin bon
après tout un bon une semaine plus tard
or là c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
contrôle au volant vous conduisait la
voiture de chantal goya avec 1,84 gramme
d'alcool dans le sang et par personne
n'était signé
ben alors attendez il a payé sa peine à
la société non franchement je veux dire
la jean-jacques ce soit est parfaitement
réhabiliter on parle de ça parce que
évidemment c'est amusant et là tu ouvre
une boîte la 4g toujours j'ai toujours
dit que j'avais fait une connerie j'ai
jamais dit que c'était de la faute de la
police
j'ai fait une connerie je lave ou je
m'en suis pris plein la gueule
voilà c'est bien fait pour moi voilà
alors ce qui s'est passé jean-jacques
ont fait c'est que vous vouliez aller
une émission de radio j'ai demandé un
taxi m'a dit moi je peux pas parce que
je serai pas chez vous pendant deux
heures mais enfin toujours est il que
vous avez pris la voiture de chantal or
voilà le fameux soulier qui vole et là
c'était une émission où il y avait des
gens qui m'appelaient sur l'antenne
je me suis dit bon c'est super tu ne
peux pas faire autrement j'étais enclavé
au parc montsouris
je sais que vous habitez oui alors ce
qui s'est passé effectivement c'est
qu'après l'émission de radio jean
jacques
il va dans une brasserie et il tombe sur
un intermittent du spectacle
il discute évidemment nuit j'ai quand
même discuté mois appelé m'ont demandé
de venir boire un verre à la queue ils
discutent ils discutent ils discutent
ils disent que tu discutes discutait la
fin du bourg et kerry joseph c'était le
début où il commence à faire très chaud
épicé y servait du côtes-du-rhône frais
et là quand on quand on commence avec ça
on a l'impression de boire de l'eau quoi
mais c'est un problème qu'on leur a dû
donner au personnage est bas alors
ensuite ce qui est terrible c'est que
ils vous ont amené jean jacques dans la
cellule de dégrisement sortant la
cellule dégrisement ça va encore un bon
c'est pas terrible mais ça va mais là où
ça devient difficile c'est que le
lendemain vous êtes déféré au parquet et
là on vous amène dans la souricière dans
la souricière s'était rien passé un jour
et une nuit en attendant d'être jugées
dans cette souricière ccsa liadé
s'appelle souris siens à cause des rats
c'est épouvantable parce que c'est
d'abord on est trois dans une dans une
cellule qui fait trois mètres sur 2 et
puis bon bah
il ya des pauvres gars qui sont
incarcérés sarnez a sur les autistes
envie d'aller aux toilettes ya pas de
papiers alors bon bah il s'essuie après
les murs à puis après il ya les blattes
les rabais et puis elles montent
jusqu'au plafond au plafond elles
perdent l'équilibré parce qu'elles
savent plus où aller
delirium tremens je tombe sur la gueule
elle tombe sur la gueule et voyez des
rats géants et des iguanes voilà en
pleine descente peut dire des choses
bien enfin en tous les cas il ya un mec
qui veut vous piquer votre montre à ce
moment là jean jacques debout dans la
souricière est heureusement il ya un
africain qui est là et qui dit tu le
touches pas ses chansons ont bercé mon
enfance
ouais coup de bol ça est impliqué dans
le lendemain vous êtes condamné à un an
de prison dont trois mois ferme c'est
pas de la rigolade trois mois ferme pour
trois raisons la première c'est 1,84
gramme d'alcool dans le sang qui sait
pas exactement ce qu'on a fait mais
apparemment c'est beaucoup pas de père
mais hélas ils veulent me retirer pour
24 mois voilà et les 6/10 je vois
systématique
pour oublier
ensuite jean jacques debout et emmenés à
la prison de la santé là vous arrivé
vers 22 heures
on vous donne des draps sympa un des
draps et taies d'oreiller matin oui
enfin oui sympa matos pour la toilette
et où quand même temps oui c'est comme
les wagons lits quoi enfin oui chiant
dur le premier soir oui c'est assez dur
parce que déjà n'y a pas de room service
et puis bon il y avait un prisonnier qui
s'appelle patrice qui est très très
gentil qui est un peu l'intendant du
quartier ou un quartier vip il faut bien
le dire quand même temps c'est un
vieille piste parce qu'on est tout seul
par cellule se surpasser ça ira vite
c'est là que ça qui vient hippie
d'accord
et puis là jean jacques debout se met à
penser à mesrine parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que jean jacques était au
collège de julie avec mesrine un voisin
qui a réussi comme celui-là en 47 1 et
j'étais dans la même classe que claude
brasseur
c'est fou et alors quand il était à la
santé mesrine voulu écriviez à
j'écrivais oui régulièrement parce qu'il
me demandait toujours de lui envoyer de
lui faire envoyer des autographes de
michel drucker en 2d de tous les gens
qui regardaient dans sa cellule à la
révision
ce qui est dur quand même six heures du
soir là quand il ferme les quand il
ferme les verrous 10h30 oui quand il
ferme les verrous et là on peut plus
parler à personne
et puis bon bailleresse que l'intérêt
puisque est terrible c'est que la nuit
il ya tous les prisonniers qui se
parlent parce qu'il ya plusieurs
bâtiments
et puis ils se parlent de bâtiments à
bâtiment parce qu'ils se retrouvent qui
sont perdus de vue pendant 15 ans il
sait pas le bâtiment en bâtiment disant
tu vois il parle de nous quoi qu'est-ce
qui est bien oui le temps en temps il
chanter mes chansons comme ça c'est le
lapin pour les deux finales à déprimer
cassine c'est ma cousine
en arabe un arabe en europe benkaci n'en
n'a que terrible quelques ellipses et
que donc à 6h30 on ferme les verrous et
puis pendant la nuit qui est là comme ça
ils temps en temps il allume évidemment
ils foutent un phare dans la gueule pour
voir que tu fais là tout cas eric warin
toutes les aires et toutes les aires
c'est comme dans un stalag 1
il ya un phare énorme qui vous réveille
comme ça puis puis alors ils regardent
par le judas il referme pour voir si
rien est anormal ils font ça pour savoir
s'il prisonniers pas en train de scier
les barreaux
alors finalement donc c'est du rap à
trois mois ça durera que trois semaines
vous êtes autorisé jean jacques debout à
purger votre peine chez vous ce qu'on
appelle sous surveillance électronique
ce qu'on vous a mis un bracelet à la
suie agir et le bracelet est donc relié
à la balise et balises reliées à la
santé ils ont un écran de télévision
petit écran 1
et quand ils veulent ils savent
exactement vous êtes normalement il
fallait que je sois rentré à 8h pini un
jour j'étais pris dans un encombrement
et je suis arrivé à 8h02 vraiment et le
le téléphone sonnait déjà il avait
préparé une voiture pour venir me
chercher
ah ouais et le jour où tu es attendu à
taxi pendant deux heures seraient les
appelait alors peu de gens savent qu
avant d'inventer le music hall pour
enfants avec chantal goya
vous avez commencé au théâtre à l'âge de
17 ans vous avez été ami avec
marie-laure de noailles dans le dernier
salon littéraire que comptait paris vous
avez connu eluard à kessel vous
raccompagner cocteau chez lui sur sa
sueur m'avait soir et il me disait c'est
formidable votre motocyclette j'adore
faire de la motocyclette en cascade suis
un monsieur cocteau c'est une vesse
passée à huy sommes enfin et vous avez
connu marine des triches grande amitié
que mind est riche oui parce que j'ai
fait sa première partie à l'olympia en
ouais et puis on est devenus très amis
j'ai écrit des chansons et puis elle m'a
emmené faire le tour du monde avec elle
dans tous les galas où elle chantait
tient la vie debout avant goya les gens
la connaissent pas mais c'est énorme et
composé pour johnny hallyday
pour sylvie pour christophe pour barbara
vivent montant 1
pour marie laforêt pour presque tous si
vous aviez pas rencontré chantal goya
vous seriez devenue un immense
songwriter non didier pour moi la vie va
commencer
émond massy essonne
foulant le sol
riche bojan avec mel et ça me remet à la
vie va commencer
excusez moi
monsieur
c'est ça
[Musique]
si je ne connais pas
le son
[Musique]
retiens de vous
parce que je n'aime pas
com
sans les cheveux comme un garçon jeu
portable ou un médaillon
le sud têtu et bien souvent le district
des corrections vous faire attention
comme un gant
tu m'aimes
que non
mais
oui
do
aussi droit de
i did he
sow
ça tient
en casquette à galons dorés en cas
premières et tout au long des jeux dits
en braille est passée les
orphelin d'un jour
oui
génie
est ce la tannerie
vivez là
les ans
du pain
pour toi match
combien
jean jacques deleau jean jacques debout
à composer non seulement les détectives
ont d'autres chanteurs et puis pour vous
aussi alors vous en tant que chanteur
vous aviez du mal jean-jacques à à
chanter en dehors des petits comités
vous décapent à 10 des cas trop de monde
ça va pas un bas c'est à dire j'ai fait
deux fois l'olympia en fait dans les
années soit 72 74 c'est vrai
jean-jacques déjà en 66 je me souviens
gala du midem ou dans l'énervement vous
avez carrément déchiré toutes les
partitions de l'orchestra ça c'était
vrai géant 66 ouais en 76 au palais des
congrès vous arrêtez pratiquement de
chanter au milieu du concert dire que
vous vous sentiez pas bien comme
chanteur qua non j'étais je me sentais
pas comment on peut dire je me demandais
un peu ce que je faisais là
hier donc à la même époque grâce à dieu
vous rencontrer chantal goya
c'est à dire c'était l'anniversaire du
fils de doc d'albert de bars
depuis un moment on m'a demandé de
chanter j'ai chanté donc les boutons
dorés - et pendant que je chantais dans
la femme enfin dans le doute dans le
salon j'ai aperçu une petite brune avec
une petite robe rouge et puis et puis
c'est pas elle m'a plu et puis j'ai été
la voir et puis je lui ai dit écoutez je
crois qu'on se mariera je serai célèbre
à 30 ans et vous chanterez un jour à
l'opéra de paris
alors elle m'a dit qu'on se marie ça
peut arriver que soient célèbres à 30
ans ça peut arriver mais quand tu as
chanté à l'opéra de paris je crois vous
fichez un peu de moins
j'accueille maintenant chantal goya
bonsoir ça
voilà où chantal goya tous envie de
baiser chantal pour l'interview de là
c'est le travail d'abord après on va se
détendre bordé oui bien sûr winter la
sérieux surtout que chantal la double
promo joutes de voir ou pas mais ça sera
coupée triple promo oui oui mais j'en
connais deux mois je les y ait des gens
qui font un double album fais moi j'ai
le livre qui s'appelle la niaque est une
autobiographie
et puis le cd et le dvd et le palais des
congrès à noël alors bien entendu bah
oui bien sûr
ben oui c'est sûr ils n'ont dit si on
faisait l'écho l'islam
le cdh et le cd c'est un best-of et ses
dessins des stocks est égale à celle de
mardi
chirac dominique afin d'en tirer clame
et qui peut deviner ce qu'il a envie de
manger bien qu'on soit clair pour moi
c'est du poisson ce qui réclame son
loyer fermé alors que le cd donc c'est
un best-of et le dvd
c'est le spectacle mystérieux voyage de
marie rose
alors on va on va commencer par le
best-of voilà vous voulez écouter les
chansons de chantal goya didier
oui
elle était dans son jardin
cheveux
et ça c'est vous et
voilà
quoi
oh
hélas
musique
avec
comédie
je pense
gratuit
m
[Musique]
allez
ok
marais
là
[Musique]
oui
chantal goya
le vestiaire
[Musique]
on se croirait au queen's ouais alors
dans ce petit coffret qu'est-ce qui a le
rang on me dit qu'il faut tout refaire
non on me dit qu'il faut tout refaire
chantal goya bonsoir
alors s'il ya une caméra qui sur alain
chabat si vous pouvez me feel like à ses
offres c'est à noël c'est à ta famille
parce que bien sûr parfois tu déconne
mais parfois cela peut faire accélérer
dj
tu à longchamp
pas
ah oui
qui alors
m
les
bien alors maintenant on passe aux tv
game mystérieux voyage de marie rose
c'est quoi le pitch c'est un petit
garçon qui est une histoire vraie qu'il
est arrivé quand il était pensionnaire
qui était tombé dans une dans un lac
glacé et évidemment ce petit garçon d'un
mois je suis celle qui va le retrouver
et je me bats contre les quatre éléments
du monde à terre le feu l'eau et l'air
avec des enfants alors la terre on va
sous la terre on recompte des rares et
trop loin pour toi mais tu vas t'y faire
mais celle des zoulous c'est déjà si on
n'est plus dans le royaume des
pâquerettes
c'est bisounours j'en arrive dans les
bras d'un dragon bleu qui me porte dans
l'air il m'a même sous la mer j'ai été
drogué tu voudras encore les charmes et
ont sorti un réel du tout ça c'est les
années canal 84 ya 20 ans pile alors
faire de votre caméra chantal
magnéto sur magnéto serge serge il est
chiant il veut vous le fassiez que les
oreilles de lapin magnéto ce canton les
petits bouts demande comment on fait des
enfants vous répondez quoi je m'attarde
l'habite
c'est bien non mais le séchant talent
des enfants j'ai fait un petit nom c'est
un petit de 8 ans vous demande comment
on fait des enfants vous dit pas avec la
[__] j'imagine dans un chou avec la
ville mais dans un premier temps car
vous dites quoi chanter vous dit tu dis
que tu vas voir tu as tu aimes tu es un
petit fiancée que tu adores et puis
c'est compliqué ce que vous me demandez
là bas donc chantal alors non pas bien
qu'ayant ils ont des parents c'est leurs
parents qui n'auraient ce nom mais les
parents sont ainsi tu te faire leur
boulot de parents vous savez bien ils
ont tous démissionné les parents depuis
les 60 naturellement avec une perte ou
une partie de notre corps la calquer un
voilà voilà voilà tout simplement et
c'est très agréable qui ça se passe très
bien voilà football en ce sens pas bien
et alors qu'en mettant un petit enfant
maudit moment pourquoi vous dis pourri g
de shit ou dur vous dites quoi mais
presque bécassine même lapine c'est la
question que beaucoup de gens se posent
chez eux
vraiment c'est tellement la question non
bien alors ça donc c'était le dvd le cd
laurent maintenant on va passer au livre
s'appelle la niaque 1 chez jacques marie
laffont éditeur
alors là on comprend mieux le personnage
de chantal goya votre côté un peu
enfants attardés
parce que finalement enlève enfants on
attendait son canon non sans talent je
vais vous dire laissez moi finir parce
qu'après il y avait après il y avait une
explication ce n'est pas juste non mais
la syrie je te rappelle que chantal a
peur elle a le trac il faut l'aider
et oui mais s'il faut pas tuer coupe
bien les bisous bisous
et bien voilà qui n'est pas la pression
non j'étais là vont bon train
[Applaudissements]
et
non
en même temps il n'y a pas de poster de
tuer tout ce que comprend mieux le
personnage de chantal goya un peu
enfants attardés
quand on sait que vous avez eu une prime
enfance en indochine à l'époque
coloniale
c'est ce qu'on apprend en lisant le
livre et que vous avez gardé de cette
époque des souvenirs magiques période
très heureuse près de saigon les
vacances dans les montagnes à dalat au
cambodge etc
donc voilà ce que je voulais dire et ils
le perdent le père de chantal diriger
une plantation d'hévéa de quarante mille
hectares il a été obligé de fuir le pays
s'y arrêter l'exode
vous êtes retrouvés à en métropole après
un voyage épouvantable et là vous vous
retrouvez à paris dans un minuscule
appartement de 500 avec des
grands-parents insupportable là et vous
recréez votre enfance en indochine voilà
ce que je voulais dire c'est à dire que
voilà voilà
c'est vrai vous avez toute votre vie et
cherchait à retrouver cette prime
enfance indochinois c'est vraiment avec
avec les pousse-pousse avec les grands à
dire enfin nadeau chavet j'avais une
chinoise qui s'occupait de moi que tu
n'as samax et une femme sacrée qui a dû
me donner quelque chose d'important
parce que mes frères et soeurs on non
pas un petit peu cette espèce de tenues
ce que j'ai et je traverse toutes les
difficultés toujours avec optimisme - la
niaque la niaque
non mais c'est vrai que déjà tout petit
j'ai traversé des difficultés sans même
me rendre compte par exemple quand il y
avait les japonais qui étaient au pied
de la maison qu'ils voulaient assassiner
qui ont assassiné beaucoup de français
moi j'étais caché dans un sou ali je
crois que mon frère était dans un
placard et moi évidemment quand maman
regarde attrait d'aller voler ce qui se
passait parce que les vietnamiennes nous
avait beaucoup et nous aidait à moi j'ai
traversé la maison j'ai descendu
l'escalier j'ai demandé à l'armée de là
c'est mon lacet de chaussure
voilà et alors ils ont bas et son bep
saison là c'est mon lacet de chaussure
et puis son parti et la maison et la
famille était sauvé voilà alors deuxième
choc de votre vie votre rencontre avec
les beatles
ouais toile et pyatt avait quoi à
l'époque vous sortez avec le le fils du
duc et la duchesse de bedford un cul de
planter
gilles ouais vous aviez même pas vis
duquel est non parce que nous on aller
dans des soirées au ajinça à paris
l'après midi c'était soirée de
l'après-midi moi je fais on posait pas
de question qu'est ce que fait ton père
ta mère et quand j'étais à londres et
que j'étais au père gilles m'a dit je
t'emmènerai chez mes parents en week-end
ou en vacances ou déjà mais je ne sais
plus déjeuner alors il est venu me suis
rhabillé pourrait enlever tous les
tabliers et autres et puis je sais pas
où j'allais tomber j'en croyais pas mes
yeux et monde il a déjeuné y aura des
gens importants qui viendront et dans la
grande salle à sergeac interview non je
lui dis une fois pour toutes la
charrette avec le sol a annoncé le
groupe au montage système assez sont des
stars les frères jamais meilleur il son
bilan et si tu le sais je le coupon
mensuel à tort ça si mes personnages je
sais que c'est coupé au montage
c'est dommage que ça fait tout le monde
n'est pas égal et jeff donc j'ai bon
espoir
je le coupe aussi c'est vrai maternité
ray connaître nar anon pascal sevran
dans le bar et éveil avait donc ces
quatre personnages qui sont arrivés et
là j'ai halluciné c'est l ebit avait
déchaîné
voilà c'était le plus impressionné que
riri fifi et loulou dont il était co 3 6
3 contre chantait à l'époque que she
loves you s'est depuis la mi juillet y
est enfin c'était sept à huit voix pour
moi je n'ai pas et alors le choc suivant
ça a été votre rencontre avec jean
jacques debout la cei telle va te faire
ça y est c'est à dire que à peine il
vous a vus il vous dit j'ai l'impression
de vous connaître depuis toujours on se
mariera on aura deux enfants vous serez
de célèbres à 30 ans et vous chanterez à
l'opéra en attendant on va baiser la
rage
incroyable alors je lui ai dit bon je
vais bien là on se mariera peut-être
chanter certainement pas parce qu'il ya
je suis j'ai pas vraiment une voix d'un
alors quand à l'opéra si j'étais maria
callas ça serait et avoir deux enfants
bon c'est peut être possible
et ben voilà il est tout ce qui est
arrivé est arrivé quand même il vous
propose de le suivre antilles parce
qu'il allait participer à la rose board
avec c'est génial chanson qui s'appelle
audois se sont croisés et ils vous
oubliez à paris vous aux régions et
méfier un mec qui vous fait ça tirait un
mec vous le rencontrez et vous promet de
vous épousez de faire deux enfants ils
vous invitent à antibes il part sans
vous sur l'a10 vous servir de leçon je
crois vous ayez persévérer au delà de ça
parce que moi c'est moi c'est nous
intéresse quant au blé un mois quand
elle ne le dit ça c'est qu'il a vraiment
quelque chose qui m'intéresse c'est que
je peux aller plus loin ah bon et s'il
me dit d'aller bien ça y est j'ai oublié
à paris ça vous a pas servi de l'exciter
grave a dit il on est obligé d'y aller
avec quelqu'un d'autre finale mais comme
je suis ben non parce que je me dis que
j'avais fait un gros mensonge à mes
parents je leur avais dit que je parte
un week-end j'ai une copine donc mon
père m'a dit je reconnais ce que tu as
dans ton sac alors j'ai montré à jimpo
nice et après je peux plus rentrer parce
que j'avais non je pouvais pas j'ai dit
il faut que j'y aille et puis je te hais
la gagner alors il avait arraché le
chèque au maire y avait un chèque de dix
mille francs et qu'est ce qu'il a fait
la maison il fait toujours ça ben voilà
avec des militants une fois il a acheté
un bateau avec un chèque de 200 francs
il avait rajouté 3 0 c'est vrai ou pas
la maison chaque fois je ne les sens pas
quoi ils allaient au salon nautique
bon je ne peux même pas attention moi je
reviens ce soir à jean minuit et je vois
dans mon salon tabarly et petits pas
erick petit pas bons ils étaient tous là
autour d'un grand enfin d'un énorme plan
de bateaux jeudi qu'il se soucie que
tout ça il ya ba oui juste annoncé une
bonne nouvelle ça y est j'ai acheté un
très beau bateau l'epd eide qui est qui
avait été construit par john alden jeu
mais comme on va faire il dit bah oui
non mais on s'arrangera et où aulas j'ai
appelé les ateliers de la trinité
s'était pas là j'ai appelé tous les
chantiers de
de rolande et c'était là et là j'étais
prendra très gentil chercher mon chèque
et puis le bateau chez zéro donc à 19
ans vous installer avec lui et au bout
d'un moment vous avez envie de faire du
journalisme vous allez voir daniel
filipacchi en disant je veux travailler
dans la presse et lui vous propose de
chanter des chansons de jean jacques
debout et qu'est ce que je chante c'est
bien bernard le plus veinard de l'avant
et daniel la nuit sur salut les copains
et puis voilà voilà j'étais affolée et
là alors pire que tout vous tourné avec
jean luc godard qui vous demande de vous
déshabiller c'est pour masculin féminin
et vous refusez vous de mettre toute nue
oui pourquoi vous avez d'abord j'étais
enceinte de mon fils et je voulais pas
le dire
bon ça commençait bien et on n'était pas
marié ouais j'ai su vraiment j'étais
enceinte de trois mois et j'ai dit à
marlène comment je peux faire marlène
jobert comment je peux faire je veux pas
d'abord je vais pas me [__] à poil ça
ne veut pas elle mais j'étais inquiète
pas tu vas te cacher sous le lavabo et
moi je vais passer une fois et deux fois
je fais passer en vente ont des gestes à
toi et moi je passais à ma façon j'étais
ok moi je t'ai planqué sous lavabo puis
godard a dit mais c'est bizarre on
dirait la même silhouette qui basse il a
ouvert la porte il m'a dit mais dis donc
tu te fiches de moi qu'est ce que tu
fais là dessous je dis bah moi je vais
pas tourner à poil
alors je lui dit tu seras jamais le
vedette jeudi je m'en fous la seule
vedette que je connais c'est ma machine
à laver alors du coup je bonne vague du
cloud
mais voilà alors après bon mais c'est
l'époque des succès vous inventez avec
jean jacques debout le music hall pour
enfants c'est vous qui avait inventé ça
oui à tout ça sera coupée au montage à
quel âge est à baiser pour la première
fois
alors le vendredi 13 décembre 1985
ça porte malheur déjà patrick sabatier
vous reçoit dans le jeu de la vérité
vous appellerez cette émission un
meurtre en direct
oui et ce n'est que huit ans plus tard
que vous pouvez regarder la cassette de
l'émission et vous dites j'ai vu une
folle qui parle moi d'abord j'avais
j'avais pas voulu la faire ce que
j'étais en plein spectacle est un voyage
à marie rose que vous avez vu et moi
j'avais dit ça sert à rien puisque c'est
tellement archi complet je me vois pas
dans une émission où des adultes vont me
parler
donc ils m'ont dit non ce sont des
enfants qui vont venir vous parler un à
ce moment là j'ai douté un peu et jean
jacques m'a dit il n'en est même pas
question thierry le luron qui était
l'âme a dit chantal ils vont te alors te
planter ça va être l'horreur et j'ai dit
ok je la fais plus donc j'ai appelé
gilles on la fait plus et l'avant veille
le réalisateur m'a dit écoute au nom de
notre amitié tu devrais quand même la
faire ça sera magnifique aura des belles
choses
on va voir jean jacques ne voyait pas
jean-jacques il ne veut pas finalement
tout on a tellement c'est moi qui est
qui suis allé au charbon en fin de
compte
alors j'ai joué mon spectacle et la
veille jean jacques m'a dit tu vois
c'est bien là tout les unes de journaux
mais je peux te dire qu à 21h40 il y
aura plus de chantal goya
oui tu va au casse-pipe tu vas au casse
pipe et je me suis retrouvé que ma robe
rose de marée rose devant un dans mon
décor avec l'arbre et la forêt et tout
ayant joué l'après-midi à 8h30 le même
public devant moi de 12000 personnes et
pas une question d'enfants et moi chaque
fois j'étais je prenais tout au
troisième degré alors quand est-ce que
par celle passée la chirurgie à la
chirurgie esthétique avec votre tronche
donc c'est pas grave on verra jour et
puis toute manière pas ce qui s'est
passé chanteur hélas oui voilà ce qui
s'est passé c'est que c'est qu'en fait
vous croyez vous adresser aux enfants la
gêne en en faisant des grimaces en
disant je vais mettre les enfants
maintenant je vais leur faire des
grimaces et le réalisateur rémy grand
bac lui il montre pas les maisons
raconte ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'ils
ont eu l'idée de mettre une fausse
institutrice c'est elle qui a tout
déclenché ses parents avant je m'en
sortais très bien ça
c'est bien cette fausse institutrice
quand je vais demander de quelle classe
vous êtes elle n'a jamais pu me le dire
c'était eux gibbons alors à défaut c'est
débile c'est finish dans un traquenard
alors là maintenant j'ai dit à sa bête
j'ai dit à cette femme bah écoutez vous
m'aimez pas changer de chaîne je
n'allais pas dire madame vous êtes je
suis une conne et je vous remercie
moi c'est pas possible devant plus tout
mon public puis j'aime pas dire ça a
besoin des mêmes pas question alors j'ai
dit bon ben je pose mon micro j'ai dit à
patrick moi je suis désolé il ya simone
signoret sur l'a2 c'est beaucoup mieux
que chantal goya je m'adresse à mon
public ils sont les enfants et je
chantais lapin et là j'ai posé mon micro
g il y avait tous ces gosses devant moi
qu'on ne montrait jamais bonne à
électives et maintenant hier chez lui le
cru que c'était à lui que vous financez
parce que dans la panique ginestet des
attaques de panique de terroriser et je
me suis réfugié dans le monde de
l'enfance parce que j'étais marie rose
et l'image a été échangé et moi j'ai vu
quand je suis sorti de là j'ai toujours
pas compris à la fin d'émission parce
que tout le monde était dans la salle a
crié chantal chantal et quand je suis
sorti que j'ai vu là la haie d'honneur
de tous mes techniciens qui était
pratiquement en larmes
vous êtes arrivé dans la régie et là
vous vous tombez sur jean jacques debout
ivre mort déjà qu'ils avaient tout
compris et jean-jacques il vivait mal
tout ça il avait il avait vu la descente
is c'était quelqu'un qui avait tout
compris bien avant tout le monde
et étant donné qu'il est quand même la
personne qui même le plus et qui était
proche de moi il était malheureux et
finalement on a mis 100 personnes au
chômage et c'est pour ça que moi comme
je suis sam a pas cassé moi parce que
moi j'étais vrai vis-à-vis de mon public
quand j'ai fait la pas et que j'ai dit
changer de chèques changer de chaîne à
l'est par chantal goya c'est que vous
m'aimez pas c'était pour sauver tout le
public des petits qui m est proche d'eux
vous pensez une véritable volonté de
nuire derrière cette histoire
chantal attendait mais pourquoi donc
chez vous dire pour quelle raison
patrick savatier rémy grand bac aurait
eu envie de vous nuire
moi je pense que fin j'ai pas encore la
réponse exacte mais je pense que il y
avait de grandes jalousie qui circulait
donc fin les gens étaient assez jaloux
succès et il ya des gens qui m'a d'auray
et des gens qui m'aimait pas c'est
normal
aujourd'hui tout est bien qui finit bien
car tu es
culte est tué
histoire pour les gosses tu accumules
pour les adultes est tué hyper populaire
dont j'aime bien tu as envie de faire un
duo toi at a désigné chantal nanterre
doit aujourd'hui à patrick sabatier
s'ils étaient les invités vivant qui me
présente sa maîtresse d'école
ah oui j'ai jamais vu ah oui c'est
qu'elles existent mais qu'elle n'est pas
si tutrice ça je ne sais penser que
c'était quelqu'un qui était payée par la
production
je suis toujours demandé comment ça se
fait qu'un journaliste n'a pas été plus
loin dans cette histoire et n'a pas été
voir qui était cette femme qui peut être
très malheureuse dans son coin parce
qu'elle en a pris plein la tronche aussi
moins autant que moi hein parce qu'elle
n'est pas si tu triste aujourd'hui tout
va bien mais le lendemain démission
totale et de gestion vous fait
aujourd'hui une émission comme le jeu de
la vérité par exemple on craque et plus
on va voir un regard des mois vous
pensez pas que votre spectacle est nul à
chier chantal goya
non j'adore mon spectacle j'irai
jusqu'au bout non dit j'adore mon
spectacle j'aurais jusqu'au bout marco
c'est pas que vous avez tissé les
enfants mais non je n'avais type a ou
six essais c'est votre choix vous pensez
pas qu à votre âge il faudrait les
laisser tranquilles les informe alors ça
y'a pas d'âge pour faire rêver non
kesselman suis sûr vous êtes endurci
c'est bien je me suis plus qu'on
durcisse et que j'ai gardé ma
sensibilité mais j'ai un bon parent
avant devant ouais alors il ya un truc
extraordinaire dans le bouquin je trouve
c'est que vous fermez les yeux sur les
aventures de jean jacques debout sur
vous vous dites que vous l'avez jamais
trompé n'a jamais jamais jamais jamais
eu envie mais non mais non parce que 1er
mai que je rencontre je parle que de
jean-jacques alors il en a ras-le-bol
vous êtes jamais dit celui-là je me le
fais mais non je suis pas comme ça
attendez avant que voilà il faut des
pressions des vols il faut c'est très
compliqué ça se passe pas comme ça
refaire avoir des des moments tendres en
regardant quelqu'un qui m'attend drake
est allé tout de suite dans un lit
non mais quand même ça s'est terminé ça
fait 40 ans que j'étais alors c'est mon
éternelle fiancée pendant 40 ans elle et
moi je connais pas encore je peux pas le
croire cependant j'ai 40 ans je le
connais pas encore je ne connais pas
encore et c'est mon éternelle fiancée je
n'arrêterai pas de le dire
et puis je suis pas quelqu'un ne faites
pas vos noms et que vous avez envie d'y
croire thierry merci alain c'est vrai
non mais moi j'en chaque je pense que
notre histoire a toujours durer parce
que durera pas ce que je vais toujours
de laisser sa liberté de cécile aime
bien sortir voir des copains
yvo de boer et des rongeurs madame c'est
un mode auto ça change à chaque fois
j'ai mis toute ma liberté d'abord il ya
jamais en tournée parce qu'il n'a pas
voyagé il a très peur dans l'avion il
est sans mal j'ai fait les malins
j'ai fait le monde entier est bien
verrouillé les pasdarans la maison parce
que ça au troisième
ça donne le vertige mais force est de
bourg dans ma tête
et puis moi moi je vais vous dire une
chose si je suis tellement tiers que je
me connais je deviendrai championne de
chistera ça devait arriver
ouais clac clac clac et puis on fait une
réunion au sommet et puis chacun
s'explique et puis ça va pas je prends
ta valise je m'en vais mais là ça fait
40 ans que ça dure ben oui il faut bien
que le corps exulte qu'on met le corps
et ça n'empêche pas que on peut très
bien ça doré et faire comme tout le
monde de les placer des nations mais
justement c'est ça qui est bien c'est
que comme on est souvent séparés en rond
se revoient et on s'adore d'accord parce
que si on est tout le temps collée où
vas-tu cac volley serré on n'a jamais
mis d'alliances mais enfin just à
l'antenne on a comme des enfants ça oui
et maintenant mais quoi nous trouver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici en est la montée
voilà
soit
très heureux de vous recevoir graz est
vraiment vital affiches et will nom son
prénom
ok et 1000mercis ans de chocolatiers
1000 m ça vient de là j'y croyais que
c'était quoi toi c'est pas nul
non non c'est fou ça vient du prénom
on n'a pas déjà cas des deux français a
dit jacques a dit il levait les bras
là tu dois lever les bras 1 m'a dit jack
adi lever les bras ouais bah non il faut
bien jacques a dit si je dis pas jack
adi qui bosse à la gare alors vas-y
alors vas-y vas-y jacadi lever les bras
voilà continue thierry gaubert soit pas
cabine
ça va c'est ça va ça va cesser bon alors
on veut on vous connais pas ce qu'on
vous a vu beaucoup cinéma mais en fait
on vous connaît pas très bien on connaît
pas très bien votre vie vous êtes né à
rome 1 à une date qui est secrète
moi je lai non tu peux pas d'avancée
secrète à je ne sais pas j'ai pas te
dire tout ça te dit quelque chose ce
n'est pas tout pas du tout je suis né le
9 mars
d'accord à rome l'année n'a aucune
importance aucune à quai ornella votre
vrai nom c'est francesca romana rivelli
si je peux vous appeler frances mary
tout le monde connaît donc désormais je
l'appellerai françois carde bon alors
père napoli ta mère estonienne et et vos
parents mais une relation assez
difficile c'était ce n'était pas facile
quand vous étiez petit
votre père vous gardent quand votre mère
120 vous avez une petite difficulté
difficultés et vous vous dit rien parce
qu'à l'époque les enfants disaient rien
à l'époque les enfants subissent et sans
rien dire est ce qu'aujourd'hui ils
disent oui vous croyez pas non sans
braquer quand ils sont petits les
souffrances de les enfants des parents
qu'ils ont des problèmes ils sont et
échangent des caractères peut-être après
tu dis mais ça ça veut rien dire de dire
est ce que tu sens je pense qu'il ya une
différence
ça vous a marqué bout oui
oui oui alors en plus votre père meurt
vous êtes assez jeune à ce moment là
vous avez 12 ans 1 donc une enfance
assez difficile finalement oui il ya
pire quoi ouais et depuis vous cherchez
toujours le père chez vos amours non
pour un moment peut-être oui maintenant
non non non non c'est fini mais
finissent alors ne cherchez plus tôt
plus jeunes oui les temps perdu oui
parce que là le type qui vous est il a
dix ans de moins de benoît et stéphanie
les réglages des panneaux j'avais la
rage avait fait le calcul il a 15 ans ce
n'est pas l'eau bien sûr voilà ensuite
être marqué par donc le fameux damiano
donne un génie deux associés une cloche
voilà c'est bien alors le premier film
s'appelle et c'est normal la femme la
plus belle
la mode est à poubelles et alors si
terry parce que pour vous faire pleurer
dans le film il vous bat avec un avec un
ceinturon
mais qui dit tout ça c'est vrai que
c'est pas vrai oui si vous avez une
trace pendant deux ans même à peut-être
encore aujourd'hui mais je n'ai pas fait
une façon c'est un vieux cinéma italien
ça s'est fini justement paie j'espère on
sait pas on sait pas si jamais on sait
jamais voilà en tout cas désormais sont
bizarres j'aime quand vous dites ça
poteau les uns
et donc la base au delà vous enchaîner
les tournages et tout votre toute votre
adolescence ou de votre jeunesse se
passe à tourner finalement vous êtes pas
le temps de vivre
v un petit peu oublié de vivre non mais
ça c'est un peu extrême quoi parce que
c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup travaillé
mais les autres ils allaient à l'école
alors c'était notre façon d'être occupés
mais j'ai sûrement vu vu ma vie j'espère
mais vous vous êtes amusé quand même oui
le soir après le tournage
non non non je me mets au rythme donné
la leçon aux cas fait limitation des
mois kg sort de la boîte
on y enseigne aux noms tout de suite car
donner en retour du roi vous devez une
carte de deux bons clients et visite une
zone appelée grâce à cette carte
francesca grâce à cette carte vous
pouvez revenir quand vous voulez mais
qu'est ce que tu as donné ta pas donné
bon client
allo
m
école famille
mo
pourquoi
g
[Applaudissements]
je t'ai vue de donner une teinte de bons
clients laurent école famille on était
sûr la grande chaise quand on est désolé
je propose pour ce faire complètement
pardonner une pause bisous
bien alors on continue laurent si tu
perds mais quand même donc la première
fois qu'on vous voit en france quand
chaises cassées en 75 dans la dernière
femme de marco ferreri avec gérard
depardieu
mais vous devenu une vedette vraiment
internationale avec alain delon dans
mort d'un pourri de georges lautner quoi
je suis également dans ce film tu es
dans le film toi ô mort d'un pourri non
et non je fais un figurant l'été à la
gare montparnasse on s'est croisé toute
la journée et tu montais les marches moi
je l'aï descendait on est là tu n'avais
pas de soutien gorge
tu m'as fait passer une journée
magnifique et dans le film de ferreri
ouais rappelons quelques couples le sexe
de gérard depardieu avec un couteau
électrique comme un jeu à moi ici à auto
couteau que justement c'est vrai voilà
des mois que un beau cadeau n'y pense
jamais oui
je n'a pas le réflexe voilà donc mort
d'un pourri puis ensuite de skate dans
les nouveaux monstres et pis surtout moi
le film de vous que je préfère ces
contes de la folie ordinaire cake est un
film que que j'adore là vous mettez tout
le monde d'accord dans ce film on voit
là non c'est marrant vous n'êtes jamais
allé à hollywood hollywood
bah oui j'ai compris mes gt mais tu vois
il ya des choses qui n'est pas tout à
fait prêt tout inferno un émoi rester là
toute la vie oubliez tout moi je suis un
python et européennes
c'est pourquoi pour un cadeau mais elle
a dit un truc génial francesca l'a dit
finalement les second rôles me dérange
pas parce que de toute façon dans la
vraie vie on est déjà un premier rôle
c'est une très belle phrase c'est vrai
dans ce dans sa propre vie on est son
premier rôle on s'entendrait bien tous
les deux n'ont jamais on a quelquefois
et une complicité entre nous et oui
conflit cheetah si si
[Applaudissements]
non
non je trouve que prendre 16 40 10 me
sens est venu très équilibré c'est ce
que c est ce que c'est vous ai fait une
analyse mme si j'ai fait analyser les
effets ça vous a équilibré ça vous a
fait du bien mam équilibrer ses mots un
peu difficile 1 - à comprendre mais on
cherche d'essaimer quoi trouver une
harmonie d'un soi même ses sacs et après
c'est utile
le solide équilibre un set un peu
difficile à savoir
donc vous avez l'air très bien la wii
non à catherine barma maliki le voile
est insupportable et ou pas du tout vous
êtes pas du tout c'est toi
non non c'est quelqu'un parce qu'on a
travaillé ensemble y compris nos hivers
oui oui catherine louis vient alors
équilibrée aussi par le bouddhisme est
le bouddhisme est l'aboutissement c'est
en espagnol pardon si le bouddhisme le
temps deviennent ouais non mais là c'est
pas le bout du dalaï lama
non c'est un bouddhisme japonais salé
bouddhisme un japonais
voilà est-ce que c'est quoi c'est la
soka gakkai c'est ça oui
ac c'est bien cette parole ce moment à
te donne de l'énergie que ça vous oui ça
se voit pas sa joie j'espère cette
prière donne de l'énergie c'est vrai
mais oui on va essayer à mieux non tu
commence comme ça fait mieux
il faut que ça vienne de là c'est vrai
ça monte aussi pas monter ça ça dépend
de chacun non je crois est à percer à
jour mais vous savez que en france ya
des gens qui pensent que c'est une secte
quand même
mais tout ce qu' on connaît pas tous cas
ça ce n'est pas ça fait que c'est comme
ça mais ce n'est pas une secte pas du
tout parce qu'il ya un grand liberté il
n'y a pas de de votre obligation mais
oui il n'y a pas de personnes nées
des eaux claires il n'y a pas des
prêtres il n'y a pas quelque chose comme
ça c'est tous on a tous ensemble comme
chacun sait non d'un beau hein la japon
président de la conac
c'est un grand monsieur mono dira s
appliquer dans ce quelqu'un qui est
reconnu par tout le monde comme un des
grands fortunés cas ça vous fait du bien
oui c'est déjà pas mal c'est l'essentiel
je crois vous pourriez beaucoup
m'apporter ok je suis pas trop vieux
pour vous bien équilibré aussi par vos
trois enfants la première c'est nike et
qu'est née quand vous aviez 19 ans le
père c'est comme votre âge il est secret
le père de nike et oui il est secret
s'est créé il est secret elle s'appelle
nike et ribéry les secrets le père oui
moi c'est tout ce passait là c'est là
mon nom ça veut dire que les pères elle
n'a pas voulu donner un nom voilà donc
on n'est pas secret il n'hésiterait pas
voilà on n'en parle pas c'est tout non
moi je sais qui c'est mais
un producteur espagnol
quand sardou et alors nike a fait une
grand-mère une très jolie grand-mère
d'ailleurs je dois dire celle émergents
tandis que l'écran mais c'est bien là
j'ai la petite fille qui vient d'être
maman y'a pas très malin et là il est là
l'enfant l'enfant du mali qui s'appelle
à cache cache
ça veut dire quoi que chalon ciel en
quoi ayem un nom indien
dre d'indiens l'indien des indes ouais
avec le turban ouais d'accord voilà
alors est-ce que depuis que vous êtes
beaucoup mais vous savez faire un bon
café
une référence à une pub française
tu peux pas comprendre parce que notre
private joke franco français voilà mais
les italiennes tous tous les femmes
italien se faire un café
est-ce que depuis que cette grand mère
vous avez peur de la canicule l'été mais
quoi
on croit que c'est moi le méchant mais
tu te trompes non à la canicule l'été il
fait chaud et jeunes et les vieux immer
ah non moi je suis pas morte
la dernière était 7 est terrible c'est
terrible quinze mois un mois avec les
choses ça va très bien bon c'est
l'effroi que mathieu est ce que depuis
que vous êtes grand mère vous pensez de
chirurgie esthétique mais j'aurais pensé
à ça même ça être une grammaire ça veut
rien dire être grammaire vous êtes bien
ça va vous n'êtes pas besoin de
chirurgie esthétique toute façon
aujourd'hui mais je sais pas peut-être
oui mais jusqu'à le moment que je ne
sens pas la nécessité
je ne fais pas même si j'ai besoin
peut-être que j'ai besoin et je m'en
fiche
non non non non mais c'est dommage parce
que stefano le jul de francesca
chirurgie esthétique
comme par hasard il ya un appartement
autres leur nez écoute tu ne penses pas
que ça c'est très beau très beau d'être
mais par quelqu'un qui a une conception
de la beauté et même même si je suis pas
25 ans 27 5
bon alors voilà alors toute façon vous
voilà le problème avec vous je crois
qu'on peut le dire franchement je crois
que là on peut se dire les choses
ce temps-là de la nuit vous avez besoin
de vivre avec un homme
les histoires d'une nuit comme ça ça
vous plaît pas vous ce qu'il faut si une
relation suivie avec un homme c'est vrai
franç aise mais c'est vrai mais juste
une nuit c'est pas son truc de nuit
peut-être même trois semaines vous avez
vous avez déclaré l'orgasme pour
l'orgasme
je m'en fiche oui j'ai fait que toi non
ah bon ça se voit donc ça ouais mais tu
vois par exemple des armes c'est
différent que ces années c'est vrai par
une quel niveau mais peut-être que les
hommes et en plus besoin de ces
décharges et des quelques façons ils
sont plus
victime des chevrets descendent en butte
à la place du cerveau
souvent oui souvent laurent fin mais
sans plus équilibré il peut mettre
certaines choses à côté parce qu'il lui
faut à francesca c'est du romantisme
parce que présente un jour c'était dans
un peep show par exemple une chose tout
cela alors là on était devant le peep
show si on regarde un film porno latella
vous dites après chaque fois je me sens
sale vous dites seule salle e
c'est vrai qu'à apprendre aux ménages à
des quizz s'appellera je sais pas moi
j'aime pas j'aime vivre certaines choses
avec les choeurs c'était terrible il ya
toujours les affaires des autres choses
moi j'aime pas mais chacun son truc
moi je préfère les femmes comme vous
kaka est maintenant les lycras dicks
ceci augure
[Applaudissements]
la meilleure façon la meilleure façon de
présenter lenny kravitz à ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas encore c'est ça didier
non
mais
je veux
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
mais qui nous
comédie noire
oui
[Musique]
lenny kravitz
alors on est ravi vous l'aimez bien sûr
oui moi aussi
attention c'est un homme à femmes c'est
un grand séducteur attention ornella
faut pas rester tout seul avec lui alors
ouais c'est vrai vous croyez pas non non
non je crois qu'en fait vous êtes très
galant mais vous avez quand même
beaucoup de succès avec les femmes les
nids c'est vrai
yoav success with commas
je vais aussi mal que toi peut-être bien
alors c'est vrai que la chanson lady
fait référence à votre aventure avec
nicole kidman à autre qui vous a dit ça
j'ai tout balancer avant à mentir je ne
dirai réponse non puisque mais c'est la
réponse avant de vous poser la question
mais je suis obligé de vous la posez
vous avez eu des tas de deux conquêtes
amoureuses desquels vous avez parlé
vanessa paradis madonna on ne sait pas
trop kylie minogue natalie imbruglia
nicole kidman
alors on cherche toujours à savoir
évidemment quel est votre secret pour
ginette garcin pour séduire toutes les
sonnettes garçons
[Musique]
comment c'est là c'est la wii me scotche
parce que ginette garcin
moi je n'ai lu je suis plus haut mais je
n'ai le break parce que j'aime bien les
mecs
non mais vous avez sûrement un secret
pour avoir ce succès qui se veut rester
avec les femmes
vous avez un secret alors dernièrement
vous avez dit dans la presse que vous
portiez jamais sous vêtements est ce que
vous pensez que ça ça aide à des
[Applaudissements]
familles hi ha dont what s interrogeant
des touristes ou pas mais qu'est ce que
ça a à voir avec le reste je sais pas
non je ne suis que moi même toi non plus
tu dis moi j'en porte pas mais je n'ai
pas le même succès lui ça ça vous ça
vous dégoûte ama qui portent pas de
sous-vêtements vos parce que ni les mini
one emportant je vous dis tout de suite
c'est la même chose avec le sang c'est
pas beaucoup c'est pas un problème
heureusement bien et moi on a deux beaux
kalb et bernard blanco ouvert le sien
wii blanche col ouvert toujours bernard
très bonne vanne dirige temps donne une
deuxième vie merci merci au nom
non il me donne une carte belle grosse
[__]
mais c'est très bien qu'offrant de toi
tu es comme ça tel quoi toi non
maintenant j'ai la carte de bons clients
à et avant que ça c'est celle là même
qui m'a donné la verna pas lui donner
une carte c'est qu'est ce qu'il donne à
bernard une bonne carte avec toi voyons
voir carte de mauvais clients c'est le
cas des collectors banon pas bernard
donc pas de sous-vêtements et est ce que
vous dites je porte jamais de parfums
m'étais jamais de parfums vous dites ça
pue est-ce que c'est compatible les deux
[Rires]
échoppes les chats aux idées ce
programme c'est dans l'incroyable
impasse de la philosophie aux parfums
sous vêtements j'adore alors non je ne
pas sombre c'est tout alors ouais je
vois pas je vois là un outil qui porte
du parfum te le demande d'arrêter non
les finitions de lausanne a pas de
problème sans médaille d'argent qui
portent pas de parfum ça vous préférez
qu'ils emportent les entonnoirs elle
s'en fout du monde c'est un vrai que je
crois c'est quelqu'un intéressant ça
quelque chose d'autre je serais pas en
train de flancher sur lui toi la grande
qualité de lenny kravitz peut le dire la
grande qualité de lenny kravitz en
dehors des chansons qui fait bien
entendu c'est qu'il peut se retenir
c'est à dire il peut rester deux mois
sans faire l'amour après ces deux mois
sans faire la mode et là ça fait trois
mois ils échouent
c'est vrai dans les nids de lenny c'est
pas le genre à se jeter sur les filles
bêtement comme nous tu vois c'est vrai
les miens deux mois tout le monde je
sais pas où d'où vous sortez cette info
mais bon il ya des époques où il faut
faire une pause
ouais et vraiment se concentrer sur soi
même se concentrer sur sarthe l'issue à
l'italie fait face à l'ancien no sex nos
sexes arrête toi toi il est en train il
va il va vous filmer en est là faites
attention il est gelé vue c'est la
dernière mode
olala t'as vu ça mais remonter les
services publics mais je suis là je vais
dire il est arrivé en même temps que lui
avait donné des ordres alors les nids
sur l'irak vous avez pris des positions
très anti guerre vous avez même
enregistré une chanson avec une popstar
irakienne qui s'appelle khadim altaïr
avec un libanais et un palestinien et la
chanson s'appelle we want peace
[Musique]
rima
en fait une chanson qui s'appelle we
want piste on peut trouver sur le site
rock the vote à une chanson que j'ai
fait contre la guerre en irak ne va pas
vous rendre très populaire salles aux
etats-unis non non non pas vraiment en
fait
aux etats unis les gens pas très bien
accueilli cette déclaration surtout
qu'il y avait une machine de propagande
qui détruisait tout sur son passage et
donc si vous étiez américains contre la
guerre contre la guerre vous n'étiez pas
patriote vous ne vous apporterez votre
soutien votre pays et dans le new york
post sont inutiles il y avait ma photo à
côté de celle de saddam hussein en dix
ans nous étions en écosse tout
simplement parce que j'avais chanté une
chanson qui disait nous voulons la paix
avec un chanteur irakiens selon un porte
clés
dans les biberons soir moi j'ai un
désaccord majeur avec baffie ce soir
c'est quoi c'est qu'il a froid et que je
meurs de chaux et fait chaud mais fait
une chaleur de bêtes rendre à la
boutique qui a froid l'or était tu fait
rempart de ton corps là tu vas le lot
chercher une petite laine tu ne touches
pas à l'air conditionné continue thierry
à ces gens c'est mon blouson en est là
merci
donc dit ici de votre chéri talent
bernard henri lévy mon vos proches votre
argent vous êtes riche
je ne sais pas il ya un bug y paraît je
les aurai qu'en france en france un
intellectuel qui a les moyens dix ans
c'est moins bien vu que les états unis
écoutez d'abord en france il y à des
écrivains qui ont eu un peu d'argent
c'est arrivé andré gide
avec cette réputation il était valery
larbaud michel leiris raymond roussel
c'est pas une chose complètement anormal
inclus en france non ça dépend ce qu'on
en fait ça dépend voilà il a écrit quoi
valery larbaud s'il a échappé qu'on peut
il a écrit notamment un livre que vous
auriez avantage à lire qui s'appelle le
journal de barna boot2 etc est un très
beau livre barnabooth partisanerie pour
je me ridiculise les libraires bonjour
journal de bord n'a bougé en tout cas ce
soir avant le libraire chez ardisson oth
à la fin on va parler de livres parce
que votre vie bernard lévy suscite quand
même pas mal de curiosité
il ya trois livres en préparation sur
vous 3,3 biographie non autorisée
j'imagine non à totalement non
autorisées ouais
et ça c'est la sas et c'est l'habitude
maintenant où ses lacets la manie cd des
livres de flics et de délation l'auteur
d'un de ses livres c'est pas d'auteur
abstrait il s'appelle philippe cohen
c'est l'homme qui a écrit avec p ans se
livrent dégueulasse contre le monde
ce livre on allait chercher d d d d
histoire sur le passé des pères afin de
confondre les fils se déroule lisez noir
sur blanc comme dans la presse d'extrême
droite des années 30 que le monde
c'était le journal de l'anti france donc
c'est l'auteur de ce livre là c'est sûr
vous a eu l'idée saugrenue voilà d'aller
fouiller dans ma vie dans mon passé dans
mon présente ses draps et de raconter ma
biographie est en effet c'est totalement
non autorisée je trouve cette idée
détestable et je trouve que les voilà
c'est pas sur le terrifiant de savoir
qu'il ya trois personnes qui passent
leur temps à essayer de trouver des
secrets sur vous c'est extrêmement
désagréable c'est un peu vous savez c
on a l'impression d'une sorte de vol de
vautours et c'est assez curieux alors je
reçois des coups de téléphone des coups
de téléphone d'amis qui m'alerte des
coups de téléphone d'anciens amis qui se
souviennent des coups de téléphone
d'ennemis qui peut en une espèce de
dernier réflexe d'élégance et qui me
disent j'ai reçu un appel de philippe
cohen ou d'un autre type un journaliste
du canard enchaîné qui s'appelle nicolas
beau qui est un mauvais journaliste d'où
le nom d'où le nom absolument et en
effet il ya il ya un sentiment bizarre
se sentir épié se sentir avec en plus
chez ce genre de biographe qui sont qui
sont moins des écrivains et que des
encore une fois que des clones mentalité
de flics c'est vraiment poète vos
papiers
la phrase d'aragon écrivain vos papiers
il ya une sorte de manille de donner un
sens à tous une folie du 100 m alors à
22 ans vous avez fait ceci mais alors ça
explique cela est une espèce de déluge
d'interprétation paranoïaque qui sont
totalement absurde
il ya ya ya deux manières de traiter ce
genre de livre le débat d'idées pas de
problème ma personne
pas de problème non plus
en revanche les proches et notamment les
disparus ceux qui ne sont plus là pour
répliquer eux-mêmes qu'il aurait peut
être fait avec plus de vigueur que je ne
le ferai moi-même ça c'est vrai que je
prendrai très mal voyants viennent y
toucher et que là je ne réagirai pas
comme comme jason mais comme un bon
écrivain jean thomas day va dire de la
liberté d'expression tous azimuts il ya
des choses que je ne supporterais pas
que l'on n'aborde il a raison il fait
froid que je sens qu'elle a qu'à la très
franc je demande qu'on arrête les
repositionner est-ce qu'on peut arrêter
les reconditionner
c'est un jazzman nom qu'on va se faire
souffler la fin non mais c'est
exactement
c'est ce que je viens quand j'ai vu
comment elle le regarde et j'ai compris
qu'on voit là il est malin il est forte
et comment il a fait ça pourrait
savourer quand même un petit peu agacé
de te laisser le privilège
l'euro est ce que tu te match n'est pas
terminé est ce que tu peux déshabiller
francesca oui on retient tout alors je
fais pas loyal et 1026 me l'a bien alors
vos reportages vous amène souvent dans
les endroits les plus dangereux de la
planète
vous avez peur de mourir j'ai peur de
mourir comme chacun j'ai bien sûr peur
de mourir mais il m'arrive
oui quand je me trouve quand je me
trouve au nigeria dans certaines des
scènes que je rapporte dans livres ou
quand je me trouve au burundi dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure il m'arrive
comme tous les reporter de guerre comme
tous ceux qui mettent leur vie un tout
petit peu en jeu pour rapporter avec les
dents un peu de vérité on a évidemment
parfois un peu peur de mourir bien sûr
on va vous faire une interview bernard
lévy si vous mourriez demain
[Musique]
c'est ça c'est une nouveauté ça dans
l'émotion c'est une nouveauté
et si je suis attendait si je suis
superstitieux si vous êtes superstitieux
vous pour quitter le plateau
immédiatement la fin je ne veux pas trop
intelligent pour arbitrer le saviez vous
oui qu'est ce que vous voudriez
absolument faire ce soir si vous deviez
mourir demain de la même chose que tous
les jours la poursuite d habitude ce le
miracle d'un jour de plus rien changé
surtout ne rien changer dans les bras de
qui aimeriez-vous passer cette dernière
nuit comme toutes les nuits précédentes
dans les bras de la femme de ma vie qui
aimeriez vous entendre une dernière fois
au téléphone
s'il est question terrible qui
j'aimerais entendre pour la dernière
fois au téléphone nous et avec ariel
mais bien à entendre que c'était pas de
marques à l'antenne vous êtes avec celle
l'année cela a été si souvent fait
qu'elle ait pas de votre niveau j'espère
qu'il sera coupée au montage c'est pas
bon non n'a pas joué en tout cas l'a
bien compris en plaine rien ne peut le
faire chier je vais pas la couper au
montage par nab août déjà c'était 2010
sur l'or c'est la guerre que tu veux
battre coiffer
je dirais un ancien ami avec lequel je
me suis débrouillé puis 10 ou 20 ans
voilà et avec lequel j'aurai sûrement le
désir de ses biens de dissiper un
malentendu puisque souvent les brouilles
sont des brouilles de malentendus est-ce
que vous essaieriez décrire la dépêche
pour la presse la dépêche afp là vous
êtes naïf mon cher thierry ardisson
parce que la dépêche elle est pour
chacun d'entre nous d'ailleurs est déjà
écrite pour ornella mutti pour tirer là
disons même pour ma fille elle est déjà
écrite ce qu'on appelle dans les
journaux et dans les rédactions la
viande 3-1 alors vous aimeriez qu'on
dise quoi de vous j'en ai lu télévisée
demain soir le compagnon d'arielle
dombasle s'est éteint ce matin ça déjà
c'est pas mal mais si j'ai droit encore
un tout petit temps d'antenne shabbat et
j'aimerais oui bien sûr et puis
j'aimerais donc on énumère peut-être le
titre de mes livres
si le journaliste s'endort pas comme
quand on compte les moutons ce réseau
cible aussi vous aimeriez un hommage de
la part de clients cimetière parce que
vous cessiez excusez moi c'est bon j'ai
lu dans nos récidive quelques discours
vous avez fait dans les cimetières
j'espère mourir avant vous ferez de mire
c'est d'accord
la biomasse est un ami il donne en
passant devant clermont je voudrais dire
des vannes mois s'il fait le jeu
prévenir pour l'oraison funèbre d'abord
le renommage par qui sérieux non s'il
n'était pas s'ils n'étaient pas partis
avant moi donc dans l'hypothèse où
j'aurai peut-être demander à benny lévy
ou alors autre hypothèse il ya deux
villes où on m'aime bien il y à sarajevo
où comme on aimait initial bhl veux le
dire bosnie herzégovine libre et puis à
jérusalem
j'aurais bien vu de petite veillée
funèbre comme ça quelques papas beaucoup
de monde mais quelques quelques
personnes quelques secondes de silence
shichahai et vous ont pas forcément
centrale par les personnels comme au
sénat sara lee des briques des vieux
copains à jérusalem comment c'est
quelques secondes de silence dans les
deux cas vous relire y est qu'elle livre
si vous mourriez demain utilise le
journal du lendemain le journal du
lendemain de ma mort parole réponses
énigmatiques à lui dire je ne sais pas
je me suis dit [__] on voit quand y'a
plein de bouquins dont je connais pas je
vais fermer ma gueule vous réveillez
quel film à part le mien bien sûr et le
tien non je pourrai commencer par le
sien et du corps à l'hypothèse dit les
corail peut-elle encore une fois que
vous envisagez que je n'ose imaginer je
crois je me mettrais devant la
télévision jeux je zapperai comme un fou
toute la nuit tous les films puis tous
les traits sur canalsat et j'enverrai un
paquet vous et couturiers quelle musique
musique
musique du jour c'est à dire si c'est le
matin les bruits de la ville si c'est la
nuit ouais c'est pas trés musique elle
s'en plaignait bernard n'a pas de
pouvoir écouter de la musique à la
maison ça lui manque
elle nous l'a dit de mon vivant les nuba
qui est fait en boîte depuis que tu es
décédé
comment elle s'éclate ça ça m'énerve
elle revit un lay up jungle elle revit
vous trouveriez ça injuste de partir si
tôt s'éveilla il y avait un mot
merveilleux je crois que ces deux de
maurice ronet dans feu follet qui disait
un type comme moi ne devrait jamais
mourir et c'est tellement vrai un type
comme comme nous comme nous devrait
jamais mourir
est-ce que vous accepteriez de donner
certains de vos organes certains de mes
organes et vivre là je pensais pas tout
de suite à un sexe je pense qu'il a
voulu garder si on ne sait jamais si des
fois il ya un petit livret la
résurrection des corps si elle existait
ciel survie je donnerai plus tôt plutôt
mon âme
ça me semble d'accord mais sinon vous
donnez rien pas de rentes actuelles pour
le kosovo des trains vers n'arrivait
chemise blanche voudriez qu'on en fasse
quoi de votre collection de chemises
blanches
bon c'est quoi ton vous me répondez
d'abord sur la collection de tee shirt
noir et je vous répondrai sur la
collection de chemises blanches moi je
l'aiderai ce que vous en faites c'est
moi je les donne à emmaüs
il aimait jamais l'abbé pierre et c'est
quoi ce blanc alors le secret de ce
blanc fut question de ce fait ces blancs
et comment tu fais pour cinq ans les
cheveux
vous le saurez pas ce que tu as encore
beaucoup de cheveux oui c'est vrai ça
c'est leur côté un fixateur comment tu
t'organises
un fixateur matin le soir avec un
acharnement terrible je passe ma vie à
ça mais j'écris à peine tu vois regarde
le fixais mai dernier chose est ce que
vous penseriez avoir eu une belle vie
écoutez je crois que je dirais vous
savez c'est le dernier mot de ces le
dernier mot de romain gary qui est un
autre écrivain que j'ai un peu connu et
que j'ai beaucoup aimé et dans son
dernier livre qui s'appelle vie est mort
d'emile ajar
il a ce moment extraordinaire c'est les
derniers à c'est la dernière phrase du
livre je me suis beaucoup amusé au
revoir et merci à vous réagissez comme
ans aux attaques dont bernard et les
vielles est l'objet en ce moment à
travers tous ces livres qui sortent
comme ça les a après ça me semble un peu
abracadabrant qu'il y aurait tellement
il y en a eu deux y'en a encore quatre
en préparation voilà mais mais mais
heureusement je crois que les gens n'ont
pas tellement envie de lire des gossip
méchant vu par le tout petit bout de la
lorgnette et donc à mon avis les les
livres ne marche pas je ne sais pas
assez c'est extrêmement enfin il ya
laissé ses communes comme un animal très
beau qui courent et puis il ya toute une
meute derrière qui veut le montre dès sa
première émission télévision quand on
l'a vu beau pardonnez moi mais il est
beau et avec son décolleté tout ça c'est
pour les gens non non il est imberbe
bon et alors alors oui c'est vrai ça
comment se crée tout mais d'habitude les
gens se sont déchaînés bonbons non mais
là je ris voilà mais c'est vrai que
c'est parra voilà c'est très très méga
désagréable et puis pourquoi pourquoi
les gens quand même autre chose à faire
qu'à écrire des livres comme ça à quoi
ça sert
ariel on va faire une interview par
amour
[Musique]
ariane emballé ce que par amour comme si
si vous présenteriez des maîtresses à
votre mari eh bien écoutez je ne sais
pas mais si c'était le seul moyen de le
garder peut-être que je le ferai que ce
beau mais également non mais finalement
la sauvette une réponse à l'heure
[Musique]
oh que c'est beau mega man je voudrais
toujours être la favorite
enfin j'en rêverai je prierai hélas je
te laisse penser est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à cacher quelqu'un
qu'il vient de tuer
ah ben ça bien sûr le cacher bien sûr
bien sûr afin de problèmes à mais aucun
problème et je dirais même m'avait même
nom mais je dirais même que c'est moi
qui l'ait tué harry mais on le sait
magnifique qu'il a une chance en
grammaire c'est le plus veinard de la
bande les gens qui est ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous mettre à la
drogue ou l'arrêter
moi je dirais que je serai tout pour
d'abord en dissuader lundi 10 mai mais
je crois que par amour ou on est prêt à
tout d'ailleurs
moi je me souviens voyez dans dans mon
enfance où j'habite et le mexique
alors je me rappelle que mon père avait
fait prendre des champignons
hallucinogènes à ma mère est donc
finalement oui bien sûr je fais pas de
mes causes et donc il est l'heure elle
avait essayé donc et je crois que lui
avait fait un trait merveilleux voyage
de champignons hallucinogènes et elle
par amour avait suivi et je pense que ça
c'était assez mal passé pour elle voilà
est-ce que par amour vous feriez la
lessive ariel à votre avis est-ce que
vous seriez prête à prendre 17 kg oui
bien sûr mais bon si bernard henri
penser si bernard au rite en qui rigole
ça va mais nommés mais s'il avait envie
tout à coup d'une femme à tresques oui
oui voilà un beau c'est une belle messe
eh bien je prendrai les 17 kilos mais je
crois que c'est faisable mais j'avais vu
amiral j'avais vu quand même à quel
point les allées et dévoué à son amour
mais merde
je suis pas sûr que que fait
l'adaptation féminine qui est
extraordinaire ariel est ce que par
amour
vous seriez prête à vivre avec bernard
et la maîtresse que vous lui auriez
présenter je sais pas j'ai j'ai connu un
cas où un homme vivait en effet avec sa
femme et sa maîtresse la banque a voulu
dire proche proche de vous oui des gens
connus non mais attends que des gens
proches de vous sérieusement en réalité
un moment donné bon je juge habiter le
mexique et et mon père était un très
grand séducteur cover très beau très
beau et un moment donné mais j'étais
très enfants est très petit alors je ne
suis pas sûr j'ai capté des choses mais
peut-être pas vraiment mais il y avait
une femme qui était la dernière se
disait la dernière descendante du
dernier empereur aztèque qui s'appelait
saute schild qui était une ravissante
métisse aux cheveux tous tirés en
arrière extraordinairement belle et qui
habitait chez moi au dessus de ma
chambre d'ailleurs et ma mère était
vivante et donc je me suis toujours posé
des question de comment est ce que cette
femme vivait l'un nous baser votre merde
à accepter ça en fait je ne sais pas
ouais et donc est ce que moi je serai
capable je sais pas mais tout ça est en
même temps vous savez très très
douloureux c'est parce que on est un
très amoureux sont même bien sûr bah oui
c'est bien tout l'idée de cette
interview c'est par amour est-ce que par
amour par exemple vous seriez prête à
vendre votre corps si bernard henri lévy
vous le demandez à des qualités
intentions alors je dirais d'abord je ne
suis pas achetable ouais ah non quand on
aura dit le prix
thème prix du m à la banane est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à ne pas
faire l'amour pendant trois ans alors
commence maintenant
ben ça c'est terrible parce qu'en effet
mais vous voyez quand on lit les grands
mystiques toi-même et saufs juana inés
de la cruz ou par exemple la fin je
pense qu'on arrive à un certain plaisir
dans l'abstinence aussi les lectrices
masse qu'on appelle oui et je pense
qu'il ya une forme d'extase aussi d'un
de désiré et de se dire non je suis plus
fort que mon désir je ne je ne cède pas
je reste comme ça en maîtrise de
moi-même trois ans real quand
oui je sais c'est qu'ils peuvent elles
et moi non mais mais mais il peut être
qu'on arrive à une sorte de forme
d'extase de douleur ou alors tu peux
passer en manuel non je reviens ou donc
vous croyez vous à ça vous voyez ce
qu'elle dit là que l'abstinence amène à
l'extase amiral ça serait quand même ça
peut être une satisfaction
nous ne sommes pas des animaux mais
aussi si nous sommes des manigances pas
ça du tout elle sera peut-être des
mammifères nous ne sommes pas des
animaux est non mais on peut aussi
simplement fantasme est très très fort
et on est dans une sorte de rêve éveillé
dans l'imaginaire et avoir une sorte de
forme d'extase les champignons toujours
on dirait qu'il ya un livre autour de
vous qui a très bien marché c'est le
livre de justine votre fille je suis
très très fier delà du succès littéraire
de ma fille ouais succès littéraire
c'est un c'est un véritable écrivain et
c'est pas fréquent vous savez pour un
bon moi je suis un père et un père très
très aisément de ma fille et puis je
suis aussi un écrivain et c'est pas
souvent dans l'histoire de la
littérature
un père et un fils ou un père et une
fille écrivains samar l'élection de
demain rarement et alexandre dumas oui
il ya quelques cas oui c'est vrai là
vous êtes bon je suis dit bonsoir ça va
vous êtes né à paris en 1974
vous êtes prénommé justin juliette
justin c'est votre père qui vous appelle
comme ça bernard henri lévy juliette
c'est votre mère isabelle doutreluigne
mannequin vedette des années 60
photographiée à l'époque par sarah moon
helmut newton qui deviendra une
militante acharnée de la cause de
féministes qui s'est aussi beaucoup
défoncé et qui vous convient à votre
père vous dit en parlant de bernard
henri lévy est à la fois mon père et ma
mère ils comptent double est ce que vous
pouvez faire des réponses plus courte
parce que j'ai peur qu'on déborde un peu
donc quand l école on vous demande la
profession de votre père vous dit
philosophe et quand on vous dit c'est
quoi
vous dites c'est quelqu'un qui passe à
la télé je trouve ça assez génial à
l'adolescence vous avez l'impression
d'être à vilain petit canard
et vous dites je suis encore aujourd'hui
dans le excusez moi non excusez moi
d'être ne pas toujours être à la hauteur
de plein de choses ouais ouais dans le
excusez moi non la culpabilité en
permanence pardon vous avez l'air tendu
crispé anxieuse
j'aime tellement la télévision est parti
qui n'en voient pas cette année non mais
j'aime bien cette émission mais cessé
mais pour la regarder pas pour eux voilà
donc adolescence cette impression comme
ça de très vilains petits canards et
puis c'est le grand amour vous tombé
raide dingue amoureuse de raphaël
enthoven fils de jean paul enthoven
éditeur et ami de votre père vous dites
on avait envie de faire un petit couple
on se disait nous on va y arriver
c'est vrai qu'on les parents on était
tous les deux on avait tous les deux des
parents divorcés on se disait que nous
on allait réussir là où j'avais échoué
voilà encore une enfant des paroles
darcis vous marier en 1996 et cinq ans
plus tard pour le passage à l'an 2000
vous partez en vacances à marrakech dans
la maison de votre père il y à là
arielle dombasle jean-paul antho veine
le père de votre mari avec sa maîtresse
du moment carla bruni et raphaël
enthoven donc va vous quitter pour elle
pour carla bruni le divorce sera
prononcé dans l'année voilà pour la
dimension je dirais pipolo et name
dropping de la faire l'oreille c'est la
littérature ça s'appelle rien de grave
c'est super bien écrit avec plein de
phrases d'auteurs comme on aime et une
flavour françoise sagan dorothy parker
rien de grave ça veut dire quoi c'est
pas la fin du monde non plus c'est ça
ouais c'est une éthique c c'est comme ça
que je fais dans la vie rien de grave
même quand les choses se sont un tout
petit peu c'est une manière de ne pas
alourdir ce qui est déjà lourd marie
françoise leclerc dans le point à
trouver une formule qui résume assez
bien le titre les votre façon de faire
raconter ces drames sans à faire un
drame c'est sa bonne phrase
alors le pitch du bouquin louise et
adrien ces mets donc depuis la fin de
l'adolescence
jusqu'au jour où adrien rencontre paul à
la jeune maîtresse de son père et la
peau la brise le coeur de louise en lui
volant adrien et puis on s'aperçoit
qu'en fait tout n'était pas si simple
entre entre louise et adrien avant même
la rencontre avec paula puisque adrien
avait demandé à luis d'avorter sous
prétexte qu'ils n'étaient pas encore
faits pour avoir un enfant qui d'avorter
ils ont décidé ensemble d'avorter parce
que c'était pas le moment encore ouais
donc il y avait quand même déjà des
fêlures dans le cristal quoi ouais ouais
bien sûr
ouais l'enfant dit vous aurez s'étend
maintenant il s'appellerait aurélien il
aurait sept ans elle regrette louise ça
quand on regrette on est malheureux de
fois elle regrette pas je sens qu'on va
bien rigoler ce soir et je sais pas
pourquoi une bonne des cônes sur plateau
et la louise veut s'accrocher aux
amphétamines
après cet avortement vous voulez lire ou
julie est en fait ce qui est intéressant
à vivre c'est de les lire c'est pas de
raconter ouais c'est ça c'est difficile
de commenter son propre roman o'shea
ouais c'est après l'avortement que je me
suis vraiment mis à croire qu'il me
manquait quelque chose pas à ces femmes
pas assez adulte pas assez regard de
tueuse pas assez bien pour avoir un
enfant avec lui pas la hauteur passe et
où je me suis senti tout à coup la
superbe comme une chenille recalé à
l'examen papillon et c'est comme ça
qu'un jour en fouillant dans les tiroirs
du bureau de mon père je suis tombé sur
ces vitamines pour le cerveau je savais
qu'il en prenait parfois pour travailler
pour rester éveillé finir ses livres je
savais que ça me rendait nerveux
concentré irascible rapide
j'avais toujours su qu'elle était là
dans la caverne d'ali papa mais ça ne
m'intéressait pas plus que ça je passais
devant sans les voir lui même d'ailleurs
n'en parler jamais sauf avec ses copains
écrivain quand ils s'échangeaient leurs
recettes et leurs dosage alors que là je
me suis dit c'est génial c'est peut-être
ça la solution je n'aurai qu'à les avoir
partout tout le temps avec moi ces
petites pilules mai
chic premièrement je serai brillante
malines passionnante et deuxièmement ce
sera un peu de papa en moi ce sera comme
s'ils étaient avec moi on sera deux on
est forcément plus fort à deux car ça
m'aidera être à la hauteur
il faut bien ça pour être digne rien
c'est comme ça que tout a commencé
chacko des bulles les amphétamines louve
le monde
au début c'est extraordinaire comme
elles se sont intelligentes et vival
rougis plus elle est pas mal à l'aise
comme l'âge de ceux fuyant ce moment
elle est là le ferai après un faux ni
tonnerre de dieu sur le plateau ce
serait merveilleux mais met en effet au
bout de quelques mois c'est c'est pas
tout à fait pareil d'abord c'est ça la
rend malade comme un chien ensuite aller
s'est passé pas si grave en soi ça va ça
pas de l'héroïne non plus c'est pas mais
elle empruntait dos tellement massive
que ça nous donne juste des nausées des
tremblements de plus en plus de mal à
cacher son entourage à son mari à son
père c'est à tout le monde que qu'elle a
besoin de ça pour se lever le matin et
qu'elle a besoin de somnifères pour
sentant mur et que et puis ensuite à la
main tellement envie d'arrêter non plus
été redevenir la gentille petite louise
d'avant qui rougit qui comme moi
maintenant
voilà comment ça va et puis c'est la
rupture
tu t'attendais à quoi je lui ai dit tu
crois que ça va être facile de me
quitter tu crois que je vais te laisser
faire comme ça j'ai lancé le cadre par
terre le verre s'est brisé
mais comme ce n'était pas assez j'ai
bondi du lit et j'ai déchiré la photo
celle qu'il prétendait tant aimé la
photo de nous deux ans marié beau et
légèrement ridicule
il y avait tant de monde qu'on ne
connaissait pas notre mariage qu'on est
parti avant la fin à des supers phrase
d'auteur merci c'est gentil
justin
il faut avoir confiance en vous
emmanuelle seigner pouvoir concevoir
alors toute la semaine vous attaché de
presse c'est à dire ceux du film et puis
vous attaché de presse personnel m'ont
téléphoné en me disant que vous aviez
peur de devenir dans cette émission ce
soir
pourquoi parce que vous avez peur de
perdre votre mystère on n'en attendait
pas du tout c'est que vous aimez bien
torturé les gens ah oui mais pas de tv
est ce que ça fait de l'audimat et j'ai
pas envie d'être une de vos victimes
ouais vous êtes peur de moi j'ai pas
peur de vous mais j'ai envie de me
servir de vous mais je veux pas que vous
vous serviez noir cérébrale
on va faire une question comme ça très
très gentil vous préférez quand vous
confondre avec mathilde seigner ou avec
ludivine sagnier
avec personne est-ce que vous avez
préféré être la belle soeur de laurent
gerra ou 2 et marc anthony delon non je
réponds pas à ces questions ah bon
pourquoi pas ce que c'est ça m'intéresse
pas ah bon voilà bien la vigne qui était
drôle là allez-y banon voulait paraître
malaisie j'écoute mais non mais si vous
répondez pas j'ai pas voulu imposer jane
va répondre oui je vous la pose
vous êtes un dire qu'elle est bête après
si c'est pas moi c'est moi de vous
torturer un ouais ah ouais les rôles
seront pas changés à verser inversée non
je vais simplement savoir vous avez déjà
couché avec votre mari pour avoir un
rôle mais là je rêve quoi
je rêve là vous vous sentez éminemment
supérieur d'un coup non supérieure de
quoi de vous non je trouve ça vraiment
stupide quoi je vais pas vous évanouir
quand même non
non
ne vais pas pleurer pourquoi je suis
venu pour défendre le film dans lequel
je suis d'accord ça aurait été dommage
effectivement vous veniez pas parce que
vous êtes excellente dans le fil c'est
vrai c'est rare de voir dans un rôle
comme olic qui m'a fait peur j'ai cru
qu'elle est assez rare de voire
excellentes mais là il faut réparer
l'ambiance qui est très dégradée thierry
alors c'est vrai c'est assez inattendu
de quoi de me voir dans un rôle comique
oui c'est vrai que yvan à une bonne idée
encore c'est yvan non mais je pense que
pour vous c'est un film aussi important
que le place vendôme parce que sur la
place vendôme ça vous a révélé un petit
peu et ce film va être à mon avis aussi
important oui je pense mais en même
temps je pense que j'ai j'ai fait du
très bon travail dans frantic ou dans
lunes de fiel mais quand caen s'est mis
en scène par roman polanski
les gens et surtout les critiques ne
voit pas ça ils voient pas le travail
ils jugent comme une commune femmes et
pas comme une actrice et donc voila quoi
mais ça va ouais ça va il faut savoir
moi ça va très bien je vous faire une
interview complexe d'actrice au nom non
pourquoi
[Musique]
et pourquoi essayons essayons emmanuelle
seigner est ce que vous êtes et gêné qua
non non non non mais je suis je me dis
oui je suis gêné pour emmanuel parce que
je la sens mais je la sens pas
tranquille quoi
même moi ça me crispe ah ouais mais
aussi en matière d'industrie angie vous
êtes crispé et pourtant elle parle pas
français pour te dire une sale ambiance
ça commence fort
tu et à toi d'instaurer un climat de
sympathie de convivialité c'est un
travail qui rit oui bah là j'essaye a
choisi on l'a fait c'est une interview
pas non non vous les affaires vous oui
mais je passe dans le fond
voulais pas le faire pourquoi vous savez
même pas ce que c'est non mais j'aime
pas trop c'est plus d'interviews là ça
vous plaît pas ça qu'est ce qu'on fait
mais aussi des émissions qui commence
mal et qui se terminait bien les invités
non mais j'adore il peut y avoir aussi
un renversement de situation vraiment
peut partir sur une super bonne
impression aussi mettons ça dans un coin
de notre tête c'est pas impossible
c'est mal barré mais c'est par un
concert
on n'en est pas là je la met là et puis
si vous la sentez en leurs deux trois
ans toute façon la critique ne bougera
pas on va laisser cela ici voilà c'est
pour vous bon ben on passe à angie alors
jamais notre fiche de côté pour un objet
parce qu'elle ne fera pas non plus mais
là on peut essayer la première question
ouais les y aller première question je
reviens sur vous tous été repris lundi
donc c'est l'interview complexe
d'actrice
emmanuelle seigner est ce que vous êtes
déjà dix actrices
finalement c'est peut-être pas mon truc
oui voilà
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit j'ai des
gros mollets non j'ai déjà dit j'aime
pas mes yeux
non je vous ai déjà dit ça sont donc
s'effacer pas bien c'est complexe
d'actrice l'acheter pour toi départ la
match est pour lui est ce que vous êtes
déjà dit mais qu'est ce qu'il me
trouvera mam est ce que vous êtes déjà
dit ma soeur m'a fait honte
si vous êtes déjà dit je suis jalouse de
charlotte
non est ce que vous êtes déjà dit
j'aimerais quand même cette interview
elle est bien sa table je lui ai déjà
dit j'aimerais qu'on me filme comme ivan
film charlotte
oui en fait le salut est ce que vous
êtes déjà dit je n'aurais jamais dos car
c'est la honte devant mon mari non je
vous ai déjà dit si ce qui ne fait pas
un carton j'arrête le cinéma
si vous êtes déjà dit la critique ne
m'aime pas oui est ce que vous êtes déjà
dit qu'elle compte laurent gerra oui
ah ah
merci bernard entier
[Musique]
non ma fille tu connais leur maman
tiennent le rebelle je sais pas j'ai
sonné
bernard montiel antisociales
c'est sa mère
bonsoir ça va on s'assagit point pas
bougé ap ap ap ap ap le rang non c'est
la première fois qu'un homme comme le
dit anti sociale ça ça m'amuse beaucoup
et oui vous êtes devenu depuis votre
hara kiri en direct dans l'émission de
jean-luc morandini un antisocial voilà
et voix et tant mieux d'ailleurs pour
vous en morandini vous demande de
choisir entre ardisson et fogiel
j'ai une question il faut jamais posé
évidemment l'arrivée des bus les
familles entières qui sont disputés pour
saha pendant des générations
depuis l' affaire dreyfus on n'a rien vu
qui divise autant des familles en plein
coeur du chômage et anéantir des
passions essentiel ça c'est des
questions qui qui fond de guerre civile
voilà voilà alors il vous demande de
choisir vous vous oubliez vos esquive
habituel et là on sait pas ce qui vous a
pris
vous répondez franchement et vous dites
art 10 ans est un [__] qui n'arrête
pas de baiser les gens au montage mais
ce sera coupé sa pensée qu'est ce que tu
as pris avant l'interview c'est ce que
tout le monde se demande marié a
malheureusement ce soir et bernard
montiel donc balance et et magnanime
ajoute quand même mais remarquez quand
même je trouve l'émission d'ardisson
intéressante c'est vrai merci bernard
alors est-ce que sérieusement en dehors
de cesse vous avez des noms de gens qui
sont plaints du montage de cette
émission parce que je suis prêt à aller
à les recevoir pour qu'ils expliquent
mois
laurent gerra il me semble non laurent
gerra il s'est plaint parce que sa
gonzesse est venu dans la même émission
mathilde seigner qu'elle a dit que
c'était un gros beauf donc celle là
énervé mais voilà qui d'autre à brûle
pourpoint comme ça je pense qu'il ya des
gens à se plaindre du montage de cette
émission qui viennent me le dire moi
j'ai au contraire au montage arrange les
gens moi c'est vrai il ya des invités
qui participa choix intelligent vous
verrez ça fait rêver
non mais sérieusement je vais pas faire
la soirée latine mais vous savez quand
même que neuf l'émission sur 10 ans sont
montés et drucker
mireille dumas non mais je veux dire est
habitué au direct alors il n'y avait que
moi j'aime le dire et vidéo gag s'était
pas on dirait au gac
si vous n'avez pas vous comparez vidéo
gag chez sa fille non non non non je
crois que plus intéressant à séville on
sait effectivement le direct parce que
ça se passe des choses où ils peuvent se
passer les chevaliers tous d'accord moi
oui je préfère feuilles d'accord parce
que je vais vous dire pourquoi une fois
pour toutes comme ça d'affaires sera
clair et pour nos amis que les
spectateurs aussi
quand vous faites une émission en direct
j'étais obligé de couper les gens parce
que dans l'oreillette on vous dit fais
gaffe quand on fait une émission
enregistrée voulait laisser parler c'est
pas toujours la première fois que vous
leur posez la question qui font la bonne
réponse
et puis comme ça on sera plus
intéressant réalisateur de films vous
avez fait des films il diffuse pas le
rush un journaliste de presse écrite qui
vous et qui vous interview il diffuse
pas d'interview tel quel donc le message
c'est fait pour améliorer le produit la
spontanéité apporter des choses aussi
comme une lionne est rudoyé ce qui m'est
arrivé à la radio finalement c'est très
bien si vous aviez dit ça dans ses
missions je regardais au montage est
sûre aujourd'hui chercher ou d'ailleurs
ouais bon ben c'est pas vous pouvez
recommencer alors entre 1100 et
reviennent même choisi c'est qui moi
j'aime toujours le direct mais jeu comme
je les dis je regarde aussi votre
émission qui est très sympathique et qui
tu préfères thierry direct la dernière
fois qu'il a répondu à cette question il
s'était dit ray de sa chaise quand même
avoir marqué lors de virées de nulle
part et si on peut deviner de trancher m
c'est à dire et ont posté à vertus ta
conciergerie et revoir en face d'eux ils
sont aidés et donne rien
mon frère alors ensuite donc vous
enchaînez je raconte votre livre là un
bernard vous enchaînez les vidéos gags
vous dites c'est alimentaire c'est pas
compliqué je pose mon gros cul ça c'est
une phrase à moi vous l'avait piqué
crocus et moi je pose mon gros cul sur
la banquette et je touche un paquet oui
j'avais déjà dit chez vous et le
producteur de vidéo gag m'a appelé en me
disant mais c'est pas trop aimer ce que
tu as dit j'ai dit c'est pas grave à
tous on était resté là quoi alors vous
continuez vous il parlait des missions
de de jean pierre foucault vous dites
zone rouge c'est une vraie connerie qui
m'a alors parlé d' arthur aussi vous dit
même avec un prompteur
c'est vrai qu'en sait pas où ça me fait
plus rire tout à coup on retrouve sa
verve
on est joyeux on est frétille on dit
qu'un ami s'en va un peu plus vite donc
il dit bernard mon ami bernard dit
arthur même avec un prompteur il se
plante c'est un nul
julien courbet très drôle aussi ce que
vous dites sur une grosse tête il se
prend pour le zorro de la télé love
story députés des gigolos l'est c'est un
peu moins bien encore pire car 10
android seraient pas qui veut du bien
et alors alors là on en arrive à bernard
tapie et c'est là c'est grave dit c'est
un escroc mal mais j'ai un escroc qui
présentait une émission naze vous savez
quand même sérieusement pas vous donner
le sens de marc bernard tapie il a été
condamné il a purgé sa peine et
aujourd'hui il est plus un escroc il a
oui mais vous avez dit le reste de cette
phrase l'aurait j'ai dit bon il a purgé
sa peine effectivement il faut plus
l'emmerdé avec ça ouais c'est moi le
seul problème si vous voulez c'est que
on avait un petit contentieux avec
monsieur tapie que j'ai évoquées dans le
bouquin et voilà et que
mission était nasa irak s'est arrêtée
c'est pas de ma faute c'est de la sienne
ouais que vous ayez bon comédien je
reconnais mais qu'il a été condamné pour
escroquerie donc c'est pas une invention
d'autant plus que dans les couloirs de
tf1
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle dans
l'escroc ouais alors qu'ils se
débrouillent avec les gens de tf1 puis
j'ai ça aussi pour vous
alors là vous savez que vous avez fait
la gaffe la grosse gaffe
alors là de gros soucis en perspective
vous vous dites et le lendemain dans le
parisien il ya un papier
alors vous avez un réflexe disons assez
attendu finalement vous appelez tapis
pour vous excuser un nom et je voulais
lui parler pour qu'ils sachent bien
exact parce qu'évidemment dans la presse
sortie juste les petites phrases
assassines
je voulais vraiment lui dire jusqu'au
bout non qu'ils s'énervent pas pour rien
et je sais que quand j'ai appelé dans
son bureau j'ai hurlé derrière déjà et
m'a jamais parlé mais sympa pour excuser
c'était pour en parler pas possible de
lui parler
non moi vous n'êtes pas chercher un job
pour vous excuser non non patrick avance
pour ça que m'est pas appelé ouais c'est
pas très grave c'est pas parce que je
compte moins que bernard tapie n'auront
un accord aux îles seychelles a aussi je
fais des émissions menace toujours bien
et alors finalement en fait ce que vous
dites dans votre bouquin c'est que vous
avez été viré de tf1 puisque mougeotte
n'était pas tellement énervé mais à
cause de l'insistance de bernard tapie
qui dit vous êtes un ami de patrick le
lay ah oui et vous sous-entendez que
tapie aurait des moyens de pression sur
le lait vous a parlé
il vous a parlé
on vous a parlé
oh
et vous a parlé en parlant des dix mois
tf1 s'ils me font chier je sors la boîte
à gifles
c'est ce qu'il dit d'un tollé dîner
finalement vous êtes viré de tf1
remplacé par nommé sébastien folin et
qui dit vous parce que lui tout de suite
il prend la relève le makhila et madame
il arrive à sa place il dit il faut
balancer une balance il dit oui montiel
il est malheureux il aiguille je
l'espère ça balance amour j'espère que
je ne serai pas comme ça a dit sébastien
pla et les paroles s'envolent les écrits
restent donc je n'avais toujours là
c'est terrible la télé quand même
l'armée c'est le fola c'est un vote cela
il vous banham emma apc d'excusés à ses
excuses et ce qui est bien la télé c'est
que les mecs ses excuses en disant j'ai
pas vraiment dit ça c'est
l'extraordinaire était une texte sur les
excuses au porteur je peux vous dire que
la pro frêche le clairement ne mangerai
mieux votre chien était viré aussi
forcément elle a été piquée par tfc
chien en direct parce qu'il adore le
direct
bernard dans ce village en vient un côté
beaucoup plus positif
vous racontez votre enfance et je dois
dire que c'est assez touchant nous
raconter votre enfance de deux jeunes
petits pieds noirs fils de cheminot qui
a du mal à s'intégrer
moi je ne suis pas pieds noirs mais j'ai
vu l'arrivée des pieds noirs en 62 à
salon de provence
je vois comment ils ont été reçus par
les métros et je suis assez sensible à
ça votre famille a quitté casablanca en
1961 vos premiers souvenirs c'est votre
mère qui pleure évidemment et quand vous
arrivez donc on dit tiens voilà les
arabes enfin c'est vrai que les métros
ont accueilli les petits les noirs d'une
façon assez d assez déplorable et vous
êtes obligés d'enlever vos chaussettes
dans la cour de l'école pour montrer que
vos pieds ne sont pas noirs on se rend
pas compte dans le racisme violent qui à
accueillir les pieds noirs ont par wes
en rouge sang sur les murs de votre
maison votre maison est caillassée
pendant la nuit fait voilà vous êtes
très humilié quand vous êtes petit et
ceci explique sans doute votre désir
d'intégration
ensuite vous arrivez à paris évidemment
vous avez de la chance tout de suite
c'est la télé la jet set mais vous vous
êtes suffisamment police et pour
intégrer cette société parisienne pour
ensuite ne plus ouvrir votre gueule je
dirais pendant de longues années c'est
ça l'histoire
vous avez l'air de bien le comprendre ça
mais je le comprends parce que je l' ai
vu c'est à dire foulée votre vraie
nature
pour être accepté par les autres en tête
c'est ça votre problème oui c'est vrai
ça a mis longtemps à exploser ouais et à
46 ans vous imaginez il y en a qui le
font jamais remarqué chez vous et fermez
votre gueule pendant 17 ans vous savez
que vous étiez mépriser un petit peu
parlé mais brisée à la fois c'est les
gens ne se rendent pas compte on fait un
métier populaire bon l'émission l'été ce
qu elle était gelée très bien assumé
pendant un nombre d'années suffisant
mais c'est vrai que vidéo gag cette
vidéo gag l'émission légère
divertissement on suppose en voyant ce
mec sourire que ça va être un gros con
way ces mots ou alors vraiment si là que
ça dans sa vie donc à force ça dans le
quotidien c'est pénible c'est dur à
vivre
alors les amis qui vous connaissent
mieux vous dise mais fait autre chose
ouvrent leur tu t'intéresses tu lis des
bouquins tout le temps tu t'intéresses à
l'art sous toutes ses formes fait autre
chose et je me suis plus là dedans je le
reconnais que c'est pourquoi bernard ne
pas avoir démissionné à l'époque c'est
ça pour pourquoi avoir attendu cette
espèce de de rebellions par inadvertance
chez morandini un matin sur europe 1
pourquoi pas avoir démissionné de tf1
parce que j'ai pas eu le courage
franchement c'est pour ça je m'en suis
voulu et que je suis allé au fond du
trou parce que tout ça était de ma faute
c'est moi qui suis rentré dans cette
merde quelque part et qui était très
confortable jeu là vous et cette
faiblesse de ma part mme
vraiment me hanter quoi il fallait se
passe quelque chose je vous aime l'être
humain mon garçon ouais y trouve tout ce
qui est plus émouvant c'est ça c'est
cette faiblesse de dire oui j'ai battu
et vola way et je trouve ça très beau
alors qu'il ya quand même un truc
honnêtement moi je comprends assez bien
tout ça je veux dire le petit de petits
pieds noirs qui se faire emmerder je
vois très bien le truc et franchement
j'ai de la compassion pour votre
histoire
simplement il ya comme un truc dont vous
avez été complice et vous le racontez
assez franchement dans votre bouquin
c'est dire le chapitre 25
c'est chantal nos mails à huy chantal
domaine c'est grave parce que là vous
êtes complice d'un truc sur ces sabatier
qui doit faire l'émission
finalement il l'a fait pas c'est vous
qui l'a fait il a tout fait croire au
public que chantal nobel est
parfaitement rétabli ce qui n'est pas le
cas vous le savez tout le monde le sait
et il faut faire croire qu'elle est
rétabli mais non plus pas trop parce
qu'il faut pas mettre en péril ses
négociations avec les avait avec les
assurances
il ya beaucoup d'argent en jeu vous
savez que les questions et les réponses
sont écrites à l'avancé par william
abitbol vous le dites dans votre bouquin
qui est devenu ensuite un conseiller de
charles pasqua et et vous savez que
l'interview est enregistrée question par
question et que ses tournées comme du
cinéma
alors vous vous êtes prêté à sarno
complètement c'était le c'était au début
c'était début de ma carrière à tf1 est
très vite évidemment ils ont raison
membres ont enlevé sabatier qui était la
star du moment et qui lui risque est de
faire de l'ombre un peu à cette émission
régionale chanta nobel c'était la star
dans le petit jeune
et puis mis très vite la manipulation
était tellement énorme cette pauvre
chantal nobel est bon qui heureusement
maintenant on va bien est rétablie tant
mieux pour elle mais à l'époque à ne
comprenait strictement rien on lui avait
réprimé mémoire d'ailleurs de faux
souvenirs de faux souvenirs ça c'est
grave et elle n'arrivait même pas à lire
le prompteur la peau c'était je posais
la même question au foie imaginer de
répéter on se pose la même question
voilà et c'est pour ça excusez moi de
vous le dire et puis ce sera la dernière
fois il sera quand vous venez me donner
des leçons de morale sur le montage au
[__]
honnêtement
il est bientôt thierry quéré à la
différence moi j'étais d'un projecteur
cette émission bernet producteurs donc
voilà ecoutez-nous bernard montiel on a
vraiment envie de vous aider ou là alors
prenez arrêté non mais pourquoi vous
voyez le mal partout on a vraiment envie
de vous aider et on va faire une
interview sauveront bernard montiel
[Musique]
vous allez voir c'est très simple c'est
très simple bernard on va vous demander
de dire des trucs gentils sur les gens
et comme ça vous avez un truc la piste
de chantilly mais sur arthur par exemple
il a une très belle femme alors c'est
bien jean-pierre foucault je crois que
c'est vrai gentil ouais ça fait avancer
c'est un vrai gentil cultiver bien
cultiver oui ça va lui faire donc je
dirais trop quand même là il m'a dit
n'être vraiment gentil et gentillesse
sur courbet en vous aide
on fait ça pour vous 13 ça c'est très
dur une journée jeux steam
il est drôle en société il est drôle en
société bernard tapie ah oui c'est dur
je sais mais c'est pour vous qu'on fait
c'est un bon comédien
un bon comédien bien thierry ardisson
tout cela knitter iv a du coeur c'est
bien etienne mougeotte lui était plutôt
d'accord avec moi donc
lui même il était d'accord avec ce que
j'ai dit certaines personnes n'ont pas
besoin de dire du bien donc bataille et
fontaine c'est dur je sais et m'ont
proposé de rentrer sur tf1 rideau mérite
de ne jamais dire fontaine et ça c'était
ce que bien joli c'est mon premier pit a
toujours que ya le mot fontaine dans une
phrase un débat times jamais il est
arrivé des choses de bien quand il ya le
mot photo jacky d'ouvrir ces niveaux via
un vrai jeu là les bras nombre et pertes
et assassiné une fontaine rien et je
connais ou qu'une chose qu'ils sont bien
ce que va nous sauter les roannais n'ont
désespoir et badiaa bouhrizi la
politique
surréaliste régulier et simplement
carole rousseau là c'est impossible je
sais ce que je dois rendre alors là je
m'en vais là je sais ça on lui dit on
lui dit on veut te sauver dit du bien de
carole rousseau il a le type envie de se
sauver mais j'y arrivais pas bernard
c'est plus fort que vous c'est au dessus
de vos forces larusso brouhaha n'existe
pas face à obama
alors oui
le mans
montsalès
je me suis dit que je m'habille m fait
romantique parole à ces femmes et ces
ateliers on regarde on regarde oui alors
bon soir c'est le grand retour de dean
draps il devra vous vous souvenez
c'était ça
[Musique]
et
le maire
à
[Musique]
cb
précise le tube d'avant et puis voilà ça
fait quatre ans qu'on vous a pas vu par
et demi parce que moi je compte les mois
et les jours oui ou non il n'aura c'est
trop long ouais ça fait longtemps qu'on
sait pas jouer indra bah oui alors en
2000 vous êtes mariés en suisse un fait
j'ai un petit garçon qui s'appelle
aulika bientôt stanko voilà et vous avez
abandonné votre carrière artistique qui
vont vous occuper du petit oui et nous
ne pouvons que vous en citer géolean est
donc le petit oliva bien il va très bien
il ya des îles et d'ailleurs où lui et
voilà la voile à olivet toulis c'était
bien cette expérience de maman
absolument j'ai c'est le première fois
donc premier bébé c'est pas évident ça
s'est très très bien passé même
l'accouchement sans péridurale cependant
sillage est resté avec 10 bits tandis
que ceux de ça
j'ai dû peut-être faire parce que je
trouve qu'il n'a pas cette femme en
france qui calait de ses enfants parce
qu'à l'heure c'est la grande mode y en a
plein seulement il avait plus en plus
c'est un oui c'est très bien pour les
enfants
moi j'achète du lait allemand lui aussi
bel emballage ensuite venu séparée du
papa
ouais c'était des très bons amis on se
fait beaucoup on se sépare du passé
c'est ça la mode c'est comme il paraît
oui donc là vous êtes qu avec le papa
donc voilà et vous revenez à paris vous
revoyez orlando avec qui le contact
n'était pas du tout rompu en finlande où
vous invite au concert d'hélène ségara
parce que deviennent ces gars comme quoi
cet exemple voilà et donc est donc au
concert d'hélène ségara là il ya les
rencontres avec
les gouverneurs rencontrer
professionnels vous avez vous rendez
vous avez déclaré d'abord qu'ils étaient
très mignons et orlando n'est pas mal
non plus mais alors ces chiens
honnêtement les chefs d' orlando c'est
du renard c'est vrai nom de loisirs lui
c'est un renard c'est lui qui a écrit le
dossier de presse orlando là j'ai des
trucs qui n'ont pas dans le dossier de
presse 1 il ya des trucs sur des choses
qu'il entend qu'ils sont un peu ça
change parce qu'on ne pourrait pas en
profiter pour remettre les choses
d'aplomb il ya votre âge par exemple je
suis né 67 donc c'est facile à faire le
calcul
donc c'est pas 35 des 38
c'est pas grand mannequin à l'âge de 13
ans est fou aussi aussi mais j'étais je
faisais des défilés l'adolescente à
l'âge de 13 ans c'est vrai il ya une
phrase que que j'adore de vous y aidera
bonjour le showbiz est un milieu
extraordinaire
je n'ai jamais ressenti quelque chose de
malsain c'est vrai ou peut-être un conte
innocente qui fait que j'ai mal à mon
avis est que tu es innocent non mais
j'ai commencé à voir parce que petit
avec l'âge la main
hugues est à dire la poche dans la
trentaine à l'inra en 95 quand vous
attaquez penthouse parce qu'ils
diffusent des moto2 vous à pois les gens
de voter non non je pense vraiment
jamais ça photographe elle était un poil
c'est dur on a fait des photos pour marx
magazine et new look oui à l'époque donc
il avait beaucoup de mannequins
d'ailleurs qui se mettaient impuni mais
pas pas des choses pour nous et puis on
a trouvé que le résultat n'était pas ça
donc la maison disent qu'elle avait
racheté tous ces photos lui le
photographe il avait fait des duplicatas
et 4 avril a ressorti les photos donc
c'est pour ça qu'on attaque et voilà
mais c'est pas mal ça a été chose en
attaque c'était surtout malsain c'est
qu'il est aussi des photos qui sont qui
ont été sortis dans des journaux ans
fait des mes parents quand même un peu
c'était pas très drôle mais il ya plus
grave
c'est une des plus graves c'est grave
quoi tirer et maintenant on passe au
musée
ah ah
[Musique]
c'est
oh
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est moi général à vannes où le
niveau sera pas mon ami josé ramos et
moyennes et la raf one pour la guinée
ferrat
alors
nous la vivons séparés at all away
mais non ces points
oui
louisa
m
vous n'êtes pas mieux quand même sens
tous les deux anna jeune et selon les
calculs et parce qu'il est clair pour
tromper 76 fais un événement alors qu'il
en 20 ans c'est tentant de vous
retrouver dans de l'ancien +10 yali
longue sieste avec 116 pour voir mais
personnellement oui mais un peu surprise
aussi parce que je m'y attendais pas je
ne savais pas dans une émission qui a
belle malawi ne vous est plus parlé au
téléphone j'ai pu écrit avant sa cellule
a c'est vrai je pense album trouve être
dur quand la page est tournée
un char deux d'entre elles est tournée
mais le bouquin et là ça vous a manqué
qui vous qui nous appellent pas
on peut tout dire année à cette heure là
c'est un peu surprise c'est pas très
beau mais qu'est ce qu'on dit quand on
se voit comme ça on parle quoi du
danemark
je pense pas ou n'avaient jamais vécu ou
dalmat devrait manquer au danemark
non on se dit quoi mais vous savez une
fois que j'avais quitté ma mère c'était
c'était jean luc mon mari c'était aussi
un peu mon père mon frère et puisqu'il
se terminait un conseil plénier
détournement de mineure non non pas
titre je finirai pas parce qu'il
concentre en effet tournage tourne on
tourne vraiment autour de la mineure
alors comme épouse a été comment tu dis
que c'est pas dur ne veut pas non non je
veux être c'est quand même prévu de
faire tourner quelques uns et le soir de
se retrouver la maison ensemble ça que
je vous dire bah il voyage beaucoup j'en
ai qu avant ils étaient très tournés
tout le temps ouais il était tout le
temps
aujourd'hui une association comme ça
pour ça qu'on vit vraiment fâché même
temps fut jamais marché et induit ans
ophuls vivaient dans ses films mais
c'est une erreur mais une erreur
séduisant très convenablement il ça de
ma famille j'étais trop trop jeune
cinéma commence qu'à 30 ans j'étais très
finalement pensé qu'il fallait mais
parce que j'avais lu mais on pensait le
manque d'eau notamment ce qu'il faut
avoir un grand amour n'en est pas
capable les femmes voulaient favoriser
ce que j'avais des bruits ou le diplôme
elle en souffre certainement et moi tout
ce que je pouvais donner c'est des films
a mêlé mans
un film dansé sais rien est ce à cause
de ça vous êtes quitter finalement c'est
parce que vous n'aviez pas assez à lui
donner traitement et puis franck avait
aussi moi je copiais donc je voulais
faire je me disais moi après tout il y
avait hors-jeu noël c'est un work den
berghe marlene dietrich renoir est
catherine yacine
alors je vais moi aussi donc c'est un
modèle et on voit que la très bon ce
modèle permet de faire certains films
depuis que les films après on a du mal à
repasser dans dans la vie et que ça
jamais bien bien marché est-ce complète
aussi heureux après parce que je sais
que ce grand amour pour consommer
différemment
chattez oui c'est maintenant mais je
comprends moi je pense qu'on peut l'être
alors beaucoup plus ouais avec de demain
et toujours
[Musique]
les blessés
-
le du vietnam départ donc on peut pas
moi je pleure pas chez moi
tu peux même pas en maillot sur la place
je rendais saab on tuerait pas moi pas
tu es sur la plage et pressent la plage
parce qu'ils me suis pas blessé mais
toutes les toutes les grandes stars
c'est tout avec tous ses biens mais pas
belle elle s'aime pas les grands dit ça
en général tu sais pas non plus avec en
star stéphane tu tombes ce n'est plus
les plus exclus sont pas les meilleurs
pros s'est placée bien connu ça avant
fin mai qui concourent à l'extérieur à
l'intérieur vient à moi j'ai à faire
fuir les meilleurs coups c'est leur
attribue tout l'air de rien que je dis
mais quand y c'est un super coup vraie
belle si moi j'ai pas faire de la bassée
a pris moi j'ai un mec je prends je n'ai
encore jamais très bon il va décevoir
tu as deux jours en fait quand même
tunis est pas les sexy les meilleurs
comme était quand même pas mauvais coups
rasseoir mois qu'on peut lui demander tu
vois il sera passé un bon des costauds
en fait une à l'espoir
d'accord j'ai gagné lui moi j'aime ses
dirigeants actuels
reagan très bien quand on freine on
était très bien tu fais là
tu as raison c'est la vérité mais
j'étais quand même cassé de chez toi 15
en 2008
ouais j'étais pas fâché contre mes
parents tous à 15 ans et demi
c'est parce qu'elle détestait ses
parents on a eu des problèmes comme tout
moment je vais réfléchir c'est sûr mais
il est extra fait d'accord il est testé
tellement la ville on habitait ensemble
qui sont vite
tu as raison mais au début quand tu
étais à paris avait 15 ans et demi quand
même bien du coucher remettre quand même
je suis arrivé avec un mec c'est vrai
que j'en avais tu t'es pas déjà quand
marie
après saint malo
quand on a eu de belles couleurs
elle a obtenu avant j'étais là je te
promets qu'on appelle de ma mère
et jamais un producteur
non mais c'est pas parce que
auteur sait pas ce qu'il fait dans les
temps c'est ce que m'ont pas plu je m'en
fous de coucher avec un moniteur 6
j'ai armé s'est affairé à vendre mais
pour l'instant il n'y a aucun producteur
aucun intérêt en scène qui m'a appelé
c'est génial c'est que tu parles
toujours plus
vraiment jean marie darmian il n'y a pas
de raison qu est ce qui fait dire
ah bon apparemment de ta femme tu viens
de démarrer elle estime qu'un jour dans
une fête foraine a gagné 48 poisson
rouge à la cites à la kermesse de mon
école je dis bien suivre c'est ma mère
qui faisait la gueule mais ouais c'est
une chance pas possible j'ai entendu une
fois qu'il n'est pas ton visage à
l'écran qui trouvait un peu d'argent
je répugne aux noms bizarres oui mais
j'ai dû dire des conneries je n'ai même
pas à l'idée du visage repasser mais le
mien comme le tien je n'aime pas l'idée
d'être dans une petite boîte de
ressembler nikon électroménagère d'avoir
la dette sur 50 et 62 d'avoir des gestes
relativement police et d'avoir une
cravate ou même une chemise lacoste pour
ça devient presque un symbole
j'aime pas l'idée de d'être assimilée à
une étiquette anti ardisson ses propos à
pois c'est le soft machin truc ça j'aime
j'aime pas on est on est si peu ça on
est un petit bout de sa mère un petit
poêle des derniers saladiers attention
federer vous réduit beaucoup oui parce
que là on raconte moi contre sa vraie
vie raconte ses fantasmes ses envies
enfin son envie de sortir de cinq ans et
a peur de vieillir
non non pas encore mais je n'aime pas du
tout et ça j'en parle dans mon les faits
l'idée de
une idée de la compromission venir
j'ai pensé assez stupidement et
peut-être faute stupide mentale à l'âge
de 15 ans je pensais que c'était à 40
ans ont commencé justement à tomber
aller de l'autre côté de la pente et
avoir des petits poils de moisissures de
quelque chose quand on accepte il fait
des choses qui me plaisent pas tant que
ça j'ai l'impression de relativement
bien tenir ma vie pour l'instant mais je
me méfie quand même peur d'être chaud
actuellement je ne fous je n'aime pas ma
tête de son premier je parle avec les
filles de pouvoir bandes est ou n'est
plus comme ça j'ai horreur de genre de
questions encore plus des gens de
réponse pourquoi parce que ça tu
ressembles 6e mois qu'ils se connaissent
mais ça je sais que c'est uniquement une
question pour pour faire plaisir et pour
justine un but d'être au fait des livres
de plus en plus solide
vous n'êtes pas entendre de problèmes de
faits divers dans la boue gêne le petit
paradis des célébrités dont vous avez
été quand même victime n'est pas en ce
moment de plaisir en lui même je crois
ah oui c'est vrai donc je crois je fais
plus blasés de vous parce que j'ai eu ça
l'histoire des drogues douces à en 81 à
86 et la maintenance et un petit
bâtiment et comme ils descendent tous à
la paix bête dans la mesure où c'est une
question de parler à moi je suis fais ce
que je ne suis pas de face qui se
faisait dans la constitution des droits
de l'homme il ya des bruits fait ce
qu'il veut dénoncer liberté entrave pas
celle de tristan je suis président et
exemple je trouve ça très très dangereux
parce que les champs qu'il écrivait
qu'il aime l'équipe de livres il a
quelques-uns gens jeunes qui peuvent
s'imaginer qu'on les trouvera sa copine
ou d'annoncer que sa mère exemplaire en
effet des banlieues c'est finalement
william brock ces dix parties explique
le coach est donc une vraie idée de
temps parler et puis on voit que cette
nuit comme une des fois où les gens qui
sont maintenant connectés peuvent se
réjouir d'être de l'être ne pouvait la
police à droite de dieu s'appelle
d'instruction mois déjà la police
le faire ça c'est interdit il faut pas
le faire soit autorisé faut plus que ça
se fasse contre signature en voiture
leur a dit il faut arrêter de dire ça
aux actes de droit c'est ce qui nous
regarde aussi dans leur ampleur et de
cassettes nouveau procès que ce pour des
raisons politiques a maintenant été
divulgué dans cette affaire moi je pense
pas toujours à défaut si si si sérieuse
mais le cas échéant donner le sens d'un
vêtement et chaque fois avant les
élections et que depuis peu sa part
d'utopie nos politiques je pense bien
il ya un rapport comme ami
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu disais que tu aimais bien le singe
parce qu'il avait quatre mains c'est
pour contourner des trucs comme ça dans
le journal c'est vachement c'est pas mal
ça me choque ce genre de brienon passe
quand on vous pose la question pourquoi
aimez-vous les singes c'est vrai que
c'est difficile ça paraît tellement
évident c'est vrai que non seulement il
à quatre mains c'est à dire qu'il peut
vraiment
tripoter tous les objets reproduire tout
ce que vous pouvez écrire lire enfin
c'est assez étonnant
mais ce n'est pas que ça c'est un singe
c'est fascinant parce que c'est vraiment
terriblement proche de l'homme
mes amis mais j'ai sept mois savent
qu'il a 4 way dont tu pouvais faire
vivre avec la sage qu'avec un homme tu
n'es pas avec à nabeul et ont suivi tout
ça les concerne ne verrait pas pourquoi
parce que ça c'est quelque chose que je
projecteurs ah bon tu traites ut très
attention à table nathalie puech et très
attention à ton image finalement je suis
pas ici faire très attention je crois
que je n'ai aucun plaisir
à parler de ça voilà c'est quoi ton
plaisir mon plaisir c'est de chanter
c'est le cinéma c'est la musique c'est
ma peinture je ne sais pas j'aime aller
au cinéma dans les médias pourquoi pas
le cinéma je ne sais pas bref de ta vie
c'est quoi un partenariat avec moi à
part du marié avec vous je sais pas si
c'est le rêve de ma vie mais j'ai très
très très envie un jour de
d'élever des singes ah bon wilson ce
soir 10 ans moi j'ai vu un jour un
reportage sur diane fossey sur
saignement qui vivait au kenya et
c'était formidable
là c'est une femme qui m'a donné envie
d'élever des 108 envie d'avoir plein de
petits sachets tour est il se maria et
sur place ou des romans ou des gorilles
cij adopter des singes suite marier avec
moi j'y ai réfléchi
bref chez merci
on peut regretter
[Applaudissements]
parce que
bien et alors donc le guide j dublin ps
ce soir c'est leur envol
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir lensois vous connaissez le
principe du brent est d'abord celle e
par équipe
hélas dit laurent ruquier c'est donc
laurent ruquier contre laurent baffie ce
soir mais de laurent préférés vont
s'affronter ce soir dans un combat à
mort et vous connaissez le principe je
veux l'interprète 1
indra you know that bébé complet sûr
qu'elle n'est pas blonde on y va laurent
[Musique]
je dis stop
ah ouais arifari à vue il a reconnu à la
première est extraordinaire c'est pas si
on continue laurent wolf
[Musique]
seni
un bon mais ça fait deux points pour
l'équipe de laurent ruquier bravo
laurent bravo jean bruno masure
passée 3e ici lancé mais là j'avoue nom
de souffler ici alors voilà
vous devriez le savoir depuis le temps
qu'on chauffe piscine points valables
[Musique]
ça
et là ça devient un tout petit peu plus
compliqué laurent dur dur
lalita
liberty kilari d'arachide qui a dit
david en premier à gué pascal
[Applaudissements]
il encaisse tu fous de brantes la fosse
rattraper un petit peu là tu peux te
branler comme en asie comme en asie
oui donc on continue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
5 0
il a répété tout le titre mais pas du
tout il a rien répéter du tout y est
l'eau est claire on continue non j'ai eu
un bon soir le silence
enfin le comité
il passe
au volant on continue lors
[Musique]
5 2 on continue
mayrand
les erreurs
à
pièce
m
je suis d'accord c'est carnation
d'édition pearson aus lindsay lohan a
pas d'autre à part il prenait part à un
mérite pas ça mérite un point la raison
[Applaudissements]
leblanc
et je sais faire quand même que mon truc
en plumes été trouvé par laurent et moi
bizarrement magloire mal à la gorge et
si tu veux parfois tu peux le gagner
maintenant tu as vu en levant les poings
mais d'une force et show-business
tu dois dire que jack de marseille
alors on est où là
pascal à coire comment as tu m'as alors
qu'elle atteint et le monde à la raison
deux points pour ma gloire parce qu'un
baiser
je vous demande de vous arrêter non
c'était très bien dans cette émission
d'un temps toute personne membre à sang
sur la bouche aura deux points
à présent les hommes c'est la peluche
après
marie france
amado
avec la miba langue ça fait 4 points
et
[Applaudissements]
mais moi
terminal en est
m
et si je fais habitants 4 est ce que je
gagne parce que franchement dans la
série parce que le blé l'été c'était un
truc un peu jean cette émission la
saison du show business c'est comme le
spectacle de la société ont continué
leur en garde ton calme à londres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
sarah n'en attendais a donné raison en
est sûre service public on est on est
sur le service public cinq points voilà
12 bordeaux
[Applaudissements]
tél
et alors
le problème des straub en bts management
franchement ça va très lentement c'est
trop chaud donc bientôt sinon tu veux
gagner six points chéri à doigts c'est
combien
oui si vulgaire j'ai rien d après toi tu
te défense pour l'asie d'asie mais des
faux si on continue laurent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
emmanuel il va falloir y aller gagner
avec la langue
ah bah oui oui à six points non c'est
moi j'avais alors oui bien sûr six
points la semaine le profiter de ce
travail pour faire des guitaristes abus
de biens sociaux vas-y le rotary
sa douche
bon
marty comme série gars et bigard qui
embrasse le mieux de tout ce que j'ai à
coeur
marc bordet la hat embrasse bien et mal
léché la lutte
[Rires]
jean marie claude vanbelle regard pour
un baiser sur l'avenir de ma femme alain
kader way enlevé dans l'émission c'est
ce qui me font la raquette pour gagner
pour gagner des points il ment bref ça
bouge un peu toute personne membre sang
sur la bouche à quatre points avec la
langue c'est 10 points le banco devant
trophée bercy entre l'unité ce que tu
imagines voilà ouais je sais je crois
que c'était ma femme ça me rassure que
ce soit toi bon je t'embrasse caméra
tout avertit un ouf c'est pas ma femme
qu'on continue laurent
[Musique]
continu-continu continue inexorablement
laurent
[Musique]
mon continue attends moi
ouais
f
[Musique]
et voilà à la fin du par équipes
l'équipe de laurent quitte à 12 points
non ça peut s'arranger
altidore vite que toi un peu de
stratégie on va leur valurent une paye
pour le super banco a précédemment
franchement c'est le cas de le dire il
ya des moments où il faut coucher puis
c'est tout puis c'est fini maintenant
j'aime beaucoup plus le blind test
qu'avant maintenant c'est la fin du
parking face à 69 on passe au bon qu
voilà premier bon colorants
la télé
ces coureurs
laurent
là
attention le méga banques or là c'est
très dur
alors là si vous trouvez ça m'a dit non
sinon
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
voilà
ma fille remporte le méga bon coup avec
un plat quitte mes commentaires ça
franchement on a déjà eu en plus cyril
s'était cependant pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux